ouf pour la route 5 du coût du tata
steel on est de retour après une petite
journée de repos je pense qu'il n'a pas
fait de mal aux joueurs après quatre ans
quand même assez spectaculaire et
parties vont commencer dans quelques
minutes on va vous présenter les
affiches du jour je trouve à toi l'odeur
il ya alors comme europe renault lâche
étaient venus nombreux samedi charland
donc avec le joueur créatif
[Musique]
ouais il a perdu une partie pour
l'instant il n'y a pas encore de
victoire il ya les plans
pense qu'il va clairement il aura une
petite idée là nous nous proposer du
spectacle jours à tuer tous profs à voir
s'il va réussir à conclure cette fois ou
encore se faire contrer il
tombe à pic au fab et un corner alors
poids taille joue je pense la partie va
pas durer très longtemps parce que
ça sent la dgrad et solide
caruana aussi car elle est noire et
vérité avec les mêmes ans après il est à
+1 vous fêtez sip et qu il a battu kari
à qui donc dans une bonne situation il
n'a pas besoin de prendre des risques
excessifs
non mieux trouver raconte
45 et blanc il a bien essayé bas presque
un miracle qu'il avait la vente à la
pompe aux nuls
tu te dis qu au même corps hier contre
visite
il peut manger un pour mes 3 c'est pas
si clair mais il faut beaucoup l'annuler
j'aimerais qu'il a un petit peu peur
mais il est encore jeune il est déjà
content d'assurer je pense jean est un
résultat positif
donc je vois pas tous ces partis dur et
trop
lourds
et les premiers kwh a été joué
d'ailleurs d'autres vies dit quelle
autre la fiche suivante visite qui est
le leader stuff leaders surprises de ce
début de tour de ouais donc créé la
surprise en tout cas il fait un très bon
début de tournoi il est à la fois
plus d'heures il est seul en tête noire
groupe de nombreux poursuivants c'est
normal ou encore dans les premières
rondes maintenant on tire tous qui avait
pour lui ont dit non
alors très vite
donc on a encore de quoi faire largement
mais plus qu'avec les décrire la belle
surprise parce qu
il est pote avec avec un disque où est
ce que ça va faire une petite tenue
après agnieszka les blancs il a déjà
perdu une partie normaux il n'est pas
déjà dos au mur excessif mais il doit il
doit essayer agrément normalement
habib mbaye peu de mettre la pression ce
qui se passe
en deux matches qu'on a tout d'un
contrôle cakin donc nous donne un genre
très créatif qui est vraiment mène le
jeu pour coûter parties essaieront de
créer quelque chose
de gagner et des caraïbes son rêve c'est
de ne pas perdre le 8 pas très en forme
car yakir on sent qu'il est plutôt là
pour
préparer tranquillement pour les
candidats des proches ont géré et
qu'elle rentrait chez lui et donc duda
je pense avec l'évangile m'a poussé jean
christophe on suivra ce à l'albanie
forest mamediarov ça ça devrait être une
belle partie entre deux joueurs au style
plutôt explosif je pense label attaché
en bleu je vais dire mais parce que
c'est vraiment deux joueurs d'après
créatif qui est le coup c'est qu'ils
avaient vraiment créé les choses iront
touche pour annuler même eu un beau coin
qu'on reste deux jours après ce qu'il a
eu le culot très
c'est la fin du tournoi pour l'instant
même si une news je pense d'ailleurs
plus excitantes donc et en parlant de
carousel justement il ya les pièces
noires contre la lanterne rouge de tr
min demandez lui ce qui est un petit peu
au fond du trou pour l'instant et xiru 5
1 sur 4 c'est très dur et autant dire
qu'ils risquent de sortir les barbelés
pour aviva vraiment pas toujours le cas
avec les plans contrecarrés elle il va
tenter d'arracher sa nul donc à voir si
le champion du groupe a réussi à créer
quelque edouard scan jamais facile on va
voir
ce qui se passe alors ok j'ai pas encore
un parti ça marche peut-être que bordés
luzech darroze un peu vikings donc il a
plus tard d'esprit combatif va peut-être
me démentir mais la situation du tournoi
ne va pas prendre des risques excessifs
et enfin ton petit chouchou prague qui a
les noirs contre richard avoir aussi
belle affiche donc encore quelque chose
c'est un joueur qui monte d'un amant et
baba vanga pas lui et prague il a
démontré une très très belle technique
aboya un peu galéré comme avant pour
conclure mais loin de la ville et pour
le plaisir mais une partie de partie
fabuleux
et
aujourd hui pour remercier kevin va
venir seront courtes sont raides merci
beaucoup kevin et bonne journée à toi
rossi way et puis sûrement à tout à
l'heure à quillan
bertal bonjour à tous
c'est pire que de nombreux
pour commenter avec une soeur se sont
fait normal et j'ai lancé du coup la
partie sans joueur devant l'échiquier le
classique je pense voilà tu as vu café
là de deux gros des lieux peut-être que
magnus est parti chercher nationaux il
revient basque est d'ailleurs
nommée ouais c'est deux écoles il pose
le basque re devant le chic et on fait
les joies ils doivent mettre le basque
peut-être pour se balader et peuvent
leur met une fois ici j'ai l'impression
vous écho chez toi
uniquement quand toi tu parles je trouve
vraiment c'est bien toi
bats pas tu ça dépend des fois
parce que tu ne pourras rien changement
mi
novembre
c'est bientôt ouais je sais pas trop
vous n'êtes pas trop d'où ça peut venir
windows hier matin signant par s'en
sortir de ses problèmes de son
le trafic leur salut à toi bonjour à
tous la voix de tous fut plutôt basse
aussi alors l'escale est basse plus de
l'écho
mais va pas je t'entends des moins biens
déjà par rapport à par rapport à hier
ouais
c'est le moteur
thêta des branches à trop gourmand oui
mon micro de le luron peu l'aventuré
c'est bien parce que j'en avais parfois
on aimerait
y est bien revenus alors qu'on l'a fait
j'entends eneko j'ai l'impression et
quand je parle rapport
par rapport à chez toi c'est bizarre
c'est très bizarre
thapan
je sais pas le stream châtoire autres
qui peuvent faire les corps n'ont
formellement
[Musique]
c'était assez mystérieux du coc
bakhouch est un peu commenté la partie
ce tu veux voir ce que je peux faire je
ne dis rien
il est donc parti de karsten avec une
taille mannequin avec [ __ ] donc apte à
personne j'avais joué vers nantes
l'avait joué moi-même en quarts 16 mai
partie
d'un tournoi de gries culture internet
ou laver les g3 la place de jouer à la
belote de jouer
je t'entends un peu saccadée aussi
refaite horaire je vois ton image qui
frise en jeu pas si ta connexion à cette
élection dans ce cas-là début mais je
vais essayer de brancher avec lui est
pas nommé ses parents quelques
spectacles peut pas revenir du même
rouge s'éloigner de la boxe donc à g4
boom embellie aussi rude coup à la mode
du tournage et 4 way sellami quelques
rares sont ceux là même plus
contre-rapport est ce que j'allais dire
et c'est le très mal réussi votre
richard rapport souvenez vous c'était il
ya il ya deux jours ou trois jours je
sais que mes perdu en une trentaine de
choristes et fait défoncer pour grande
et le site est très mal passée à huy
j'imagine qu'il est beau serge ondobo
actuelle une bonne ouverture mais après
oui oui c'était pas l'ouverture le
problème mais
là ça va finalement contrairement à ce
qu'on disait de temps prend 2 s'annonce
une partie plutôt hyper animé a très peu
tranchant donc curieux de voir ce que
magnus après pareil ici
alors est-ce que tu as eu le temps de
chien pas de nous mêmes sont
ok en gros réseau ça arrive
voir si ça change quelque chose on
espère au quesnoy les samedis peut jouer
et beaucoup de coups dans guéri je
propose qu'on allait faire un tour
directement
sa crème humain mais quand je prie que
ça alors un point depuis le début
on a une petrov quan
toujours aussi à la mode
clairement les intentions de visiter
silva d'être solides avec les pièces
noires normale dans sa situation il est
seul en tête
et c'est du très classique ah oui
forme de positions souvent symétrie
gardant dans la pétrole
et ses cadres qui par ailleurs est
extrêmement
extrêmement jouer au plus haut niveau
j'allais de joie et la douleur
n'est pas comme en
mêlée mais sur son téléphone maintenant
ce que ça va mieux je suis content de
bien tenir la saa drame d'avoir ou avoir
interdit
ces sagas d'été jouer donc il décide de
fermer aniche ah bon je suppose et que
nous faut voir qu lancée celle pour
rester dans sa catégorie
d'un premier set mais tellement
courageux mais attention aux petits
pieds on va vous prayssas et tu veux
du puzzle rush de base ça va pas rien
dans cette partie ce serait à savoir
adige perdre comme ça avait
du sens et 7 est bel et bien possible et
et après j meilleur du foot roja du
cavaly ces trois mauvais s'était logé ce
cahier des deux peut-être fait cavalier
mais vrai que c'est une position je vous
fais assez tranquille pour les noirs et
sûrement des petites vidéos on va voir
parce qu'à préparer le le facétieux
joueur néerlandais
oui ça reste très solide pour mémoire et
pour les noirs est ce que vous entendez
mieux stouff au passage
on va continuer un petit peu de voir les
premières ouvertures avec tête et si
bien qu entre autres caruana
notre habit charcute heures
d'espagnol de ses bureaux après où les
epci j'ai mes impressions plata freeze
ou alors
monsieur
je m'inquiète pour ta santé
oui peut-être tu vas revenir vite
alors pendant que je t'offre
reviennent parmi nos on va regarder ça
s'est passé entre ici pégoulade
on envisager plutôt une partie solide
tranquille connaissant le stim des
joueurs bavarois carrément perdu je
t'offre de
te bouffer le mythe du coup ça fait
bugger lecam puisqu'on les pros là-bas
on attend qu'ils reviennent
je pense c'est vraiment son changement
de connexion
je vais pas essayer de tout régler
depuis des mois la terre de ces 30
secondes a priori
c'est ça au jour 2 3 soleil et le retour
alors si toof je vais au tour par
milliers
pas la technique du siècle la faute
alors oui ce sera mieux quand il sera de
retour en france je pense qu'on pourra
sa sortie un plus puis facilement bien
[Musique]
donc on était en train de se lancer sur
les super coq armada
et spectacles et pièces gorge donc
qu'est partie sur du des gaffes
et et 6ème radieux
dure encore un archi classique
et celles ci sont la vue je crois qu'on
tire ça qui est ce qu a joué sept
c'est plus ma cheville droite quasiment
sûr voilà le temps de me rendre
tous deux des cinq plus grands
je sais plus mais on déjà vu dans cet
ordre à cette ouverture
et cette dame ces deux des six g4 est
décidément je garde les joueurs se sont
donnés le mot
ils veulent faire plaisir aux
gros beurre son nombre des francophones
qui va tendre
dans cette position c'est intéressant ça
existe un écart éléments soient
corrigées après midi j'ai certes
par exemple
je sais que c'est possible échec
normalement mon repas trop copieux 40
hockey de l'apab en gère
ne l'a pas manger fabiano il a joué le
plus paisible h6 pour
empêcher âgées stocks
écoulés de
caisse qui souffrait base et il y avait
eu 24 votre sérieux handicap pour
essayer de faire un sac dans le pensent
juste les noirs
ils vont courir normalement maintenant
on peut le manger celle ci a pu h3 peut
pas reculer celle où il avait résidé
rottner la junte 5 à base de tourbières
sont mauvaises
pratiques
prises dans ces 4 et la raison il
pourrait le centre vous voyez la
réaction de rencontre les noirs les
blancs rouges égard la balle et blanc
veulent réagir au sens complet il ya des
frais dans sa gamme et en chipant à voir
si si caruana réagir et e5 avec kamal et
ds5 comex et ça
au centre vraiment ont dit publiquement
à l'aide un peu plus 4 réactions au
second quand vous faites attaquer un sur
une aile faut pas vous laisser faire et
du coup
réaction très logique de karrada et tour
jerrett et joël part parce qu'elles
causent suivi de
deux baies 5 dont 42 aux quais bas
peut-être que t'as pas vouloir prendre
mon pions bah je vais m'accrocher à la
légion de plus
pour cette échelle va aussi assez
classique dans ce genre d'ouverture où
les les candidats ou les plans
sacrifions ne récupère pas même en
échange ils vont avoir le centre
potentiellement cette avancée avec le
4-5-1 qui peut s'avérer dangereuse
proposition très intéressante qui
augurent aussi d'un beau combat entre
les deux joueurs finalement après ian
thomas vidéo c'est à 4 même les trois
pour les blancs il est mobilisé les
trois mêmes c'est pour mes 3 et
apprendre quoi
vraiment attaquer les fiancés et à
mémoire il ya une idée vraiment
intéressante en tout cas et
et moi je fais ça parce qu'on avait dix
mois de france est un que la partie n
est pas duré très longtemps avec eux et
c'est plus que deux petits bras et au
final elle en
fait les deux joueurs qu'on avait
annoncé un peu petit bras à protéger ces
sites est qu ils jouent tous les deux et
quatre aimante carrément inédit de
rentrer chez vous laissez nous vos
joueurs de là pour prendre des risques
tant mieux le poteau pour le spectacle
et que dire
du camp des loges répète c'est de leur
surface comme un simple jouet que blanc
un petit peu et du couvoir après comment
car axel
joue pas cette carte fait il sait que
quand bien dessous j'ai cassé l'arrêt
disons donc voir
et donc on a vu ses baies qu il s'est
rassis et d'hôtels coup il a répondu à
tempo à 4 pour autant dire qu'il sera
dans sa prépa calme on allait
certainement aussi il doit il va
connaître mais je
ne suis pas un peu comme ça tu es baup
semaine car anna il a eu 27
km entre quatre et cinq années oui donc
nécessaire ne l'aurait l'évier
tranquillement c'est ça les deux clubs
est la position
et le temps pour aller voir
[Musique]
des mandats c'est la même chose avec
emma
d'un tract c'est vraiment mon poulain a
revu j'ai vraiment pas changé pour rien
et à tous je la tenais et c'est l'amour
et parfois aussi c'est une
joue pas la news on avait travaillé à
l'époque avec cavaliers issus des 5
et 4 notre voisine dams et de tireurs
accroît triste d'apprendre et 5 et 5,5
ici à plein de monde possible mais des
points est simple et un coût des dégâts
et le bon coup ici oui cette tension
centre
directement la cdpa ya beaucoup de
choses à regarder dans quel ordre
culture mondiale partout roy peignoir
ont déjà vu leur moral a dès lors quand
même loin d'avoir fini leur
développement mais ici on continue on
fait des processeurs et des gars donc
pareil ça c'est
c'est connu de tout
faire en train qui les gens là ici
aurait conclu van hamme archives plus il
faut la mettre je crois que c'est
ces deux je crois comme ça
vient de là mais j'ai trois qui peut se
jouer je crois
mais en fait normalement les noirs
veulent jean floureusse avant et après
le cabaye qui vend à 6 et manger ses
sacs et l'idée c'est vraiment son
cavalier à 6 ou cavaliers 17 mai on va
montrer ses 5 îles si les blancs jouer
garde quand vous prendrez mayorat tour
durera 5 et
en patchwork dans l'année nous aurons
manière générale et bâle et noir ont
coutances en complet sera content ou à
vendre notre développement et là vous
voyez que le chez les blancs indiens en
leur prouvant en fin de bail en juin le
roi en peur et du coup provoqué des
coulées petit côté et blanc on
est même là en train d'en manger 3 et 20
il est vrai que l'on se met quand même
devant le plonger qui doit nous empêcher
de proposer deux basques avec un fond
noir en d4 on sait maintenant comment va
réussir à certains de fou s'ils ont joué
3 eh bien on risque de casser un peu la
structure devrait les nuls pour le roi
blanc
ça peut être dangereux et
et exemples étrangers public pourra donc
avoir contre sa joue alors je suis pas
sûr de la b3 cette année fait
comment peut-être date est roi du court
ouais je pense qu'il faut mettre les
bases de données sur le cac 40 je suis
un peu attention un plus un groupe de
travail
s'est plutôt dams et de mesdames g3 se
joue aussi celles et tous ceux
[Musique]
qui me semblait et d'absolu du coucou je
sentirai
peuvent essayer de solidifier ce pion en
hiver le faut
rabat les sept ans donc ça doit être
vrai à l'époque et bd bande de nuls
aussi
mais bon je pense pas que rapports et
avis de ses revenus rapides actuellement
et
donc sur eux croient qu'il est elle
adaptée tout naturellement sur trois est
ce que vous gaver les 17 cavaliers à 6
sur 6 x
ok
j'ai labouré là ça change rien
pour moi j'aimerais bien
extrême c5 puisqu'avant de sas qui
pendent sur des cartes pour le mans
ouest expliqué malgré cette à la place
mais 4 à 5 ouais
le sceptre pour envoyer ma
base on va rentrer en irak et qui
réfléchit longtemps ici alors que des
cas où c'est quand même
un coup à priori assez en principal dans
cette position
la seconde
vous avez l'habitude vous avez très bien
la forme en courant
est ce qu'on entend toujours là pour
voir juste et font entendre non je pense
pas à chela
ok ça marche
bon bah du coup les serbes de cette
position pour l'instant on n'a pas fait
le tour des stades on va le voir
ok ok pietro on va voir la pause mais
mangez pas trop d'où ça vient c'est
bizarre à le pratiquer la connexion du
stuff
on sait jamais exactement pour
identifier le problème dans son box au
monde
voir site du bois vous a préparé une
petite surprise
à l'ouverture alors venue un banc
comment je suis revenue je te vois
qu'on a de nouveau mis en garde pour
l'instant la patrie on sait qu'un d'à
priori ok
donc en scène pareille ça c'est partie
théorique
près c'est pas du tout mon répertoire
mais je ne connais pas trop
quelle idée de ses
défenses et 4 j'imagine ça l'idée
principale je vois pas d'autre voie
reprendre avec lecavalier
théo standard de mettre la dame en c2
donc j'ai pas quelle est la nuance avec
l'autre les deux coups
certainement une
tête après ça peut transposer aussi mais
bon peut-être cette idée de tous peuvent
avoir ce que ça que c'est un besoin de
vraiment tout cas champions il a pas
l'air d'avoir été vraiment déstabiliser
en ce qu'il a et la complète ou les
visites il petit avant goût de cette
tente est rien
ces six donc on consolide le centre le
fonds qui repart à une meilleure
diagonale
prise d' espaces et il part auquel
qu'est ce qu'il va faire une espèce de
d'attac l'attaqué stand yen puisque
schéma
ça paraît pas si évident a vu la
configuration
h et invite au sacrifice qui ne marche
pas pour l'instant mais
bien c'est bon tout le monde entier
je crois que c'est un an
et donc ici pourquoi voir quel est
l'apport véritable aide annoncée entre
on peut avoir l'impression qu'elle
annonçait 2 qui libérer plus facilement
le tour
c'est assez obscure pour l'instant pour
nous je pense
par abonné en
retourné sur prague
si tu veux je vous le dis ok
mon dossier qui étaient les trois quarts
étaient jeunes
dames les trois voix
par rapport
il faut le cavaliere
pourrait céder ses sacs
ou est ce que tu veux
c'est logique ultra se font plus tard
kim a joué ici un
sur cavani 17
ce qui se joue en quatre équipes je vais
4 pour défendre l'euro
il peut aussi jouer cavalier trois ans
pour empêcher de st et tous ces jeux
qu'on style avec en rappant
hockey et
joubert
hommage aux attaques pour
ouvrir colonna et
[Musique]
pour mère par exemple 130 bénévoles de
la ville pour apprend à prendre des
coups est simple on voit que les noirs
quand même j'aime bien les doigts de
réussir
ta l'accolade à sans gros retard de
développement les blancs
c'est un risque et cette ouverture pour
les plantes donc du coup d'état un petit
peu bizarre
et alpages de bep cap caval est froid et
et je peux en quoi notamment par par
cali le laurier ok donc sur cavale et f3
le bon coup ce n'est pas cavalier
prendre un
bon problème des matières premières et
des croix la motion n'a pas joué
à la place de 45 83 les questions
d'argent que ça
si on prend qu'est-ce qui se passe j'en
perds ma lettre aux médecins heba fatma
dans mon genre 7 5
et 10 ans reste la menace avec cavaliers
ses 5 ans le cadre
aussi faut être 5 qui peut arriver avec
des droits j'ai aussi tout 8 et le
biladi droite au réveil comme quoi on
disait j'ai quand même du mal à a
vraiment développé
avec une pointe à 7 heures le coup et
3,5 qui est hyper choix
d'amd et à une liane roy cotant 1 et g3
n'est pas possible donc doublement
encore
ici assez calmes risquer la colonne
s'est ouverte
et le mieux ce presque maintenant
camélia
d'impôt maintenant à merde bon là quand
je vous dit qu'on allait tellement vite
ça marche pourrait dire f3
je suis fait mal à bon droit quand même
mais voilà
et est du coup du coup ici
c'est un pari
et le produit unique en europe afin de
cavaillé et je crois que cela la grande
ligne ok si dociles des ventes à richard
ouais donc son grand roque
cavaliers prend 2,5 et un peu la tromper
avec pas rien qu'à
lui plaira voici compliqué les banques
il doit prendre au cabba les 3 à 5 ans
comme 2005 strike ou doit un petit peu
plus concrète
mais après après damas n'a pas vraiment
gt4 à cause du camel et les trois chaque
fois donc c'est compliqué mais cabaye
est arrivé normand le plus bel arbre et
du coup l'année la meilleure ligne
centre en vrac
apparemment le top 5 qui est un frein et
des jeux comme
toi c'est un grand spécialiste des
voitures de 5,3 et damas cinq est en
fait
après
après dun à 5 et binger
bonne pression d'attac jusqu'à 1.5 qui
va arriver le prix qui variera entre 5
et j'ai des menaces quand même assez
assez important
et
à double tranchant ça va être très chaud
a frappé depuis pas vous montrer la
prépa
je retourne montrer sa meilleur buteur
on voit que
c'est compliqué ni dieu - les analyses
que j'ai fait il ya quasiment dix ans
elles sont assez bonne analyse
mais je trouve les amendes a maintenant
il doit actualiser un dossier et c'est
un peu plus loin donc voir jusqu'à 25 c
est donc en tout cas c'est une particule
d'être animée et très intéressant là il
avait travaillé c'est très cool ouais
mais là on prétend avoir en revanche
moi j'attends dans un rapport qu'un
câlin la jet et pour ses vingt minutes
et peut-être du mal à se guider sa peut
être très dangereux de genre
d'opposition mieux connaître pour le
court vieux à quel point ce complexe
on va voir alors comment ça évolue quel
jour je te demandais pas encore allé
jeter un oeil on n'a pas vu pas votre
fort reste baba diarra of
ces packs aux pratiques assez
d'espagnols en
vain une forêt ce cas les pièces
blanches qui fait partie des
poursuivants m d'ennemis sur chalmé
d'ailleurs comme à béziers rohff annonce
avec beaucoup de réussite il a quitté ce
score vu qu'il a déjà battu 12 heures
dans une position désespérée
initialement
la pression 4 et
puis je suis ok à kad merad qui ferment
issifou trois ont souvent ajouté que les
trois lapins de joie gap souvent ici
c'est 3 gagne le
hockey des fois il faut qu'il peut aussi
peut-être revenir assez souvent et
aucun cas la sentence 1 4 b 4 x 3 x 7
à 5 c'est de fixer une faiblesse à long
terme aura 6 puis un petit peu comme
ceux révélés faibles peut être assez
facilement attaquable aussi on n'a pas
envie de devoir laisser une tour à sa
protection quoi petit rock
dub détroit d'ailleurs d'al ahly six
cavaliers ces cinq chats sont vraiment
la dame ou à gagner peut-être la paire
de faux et avec les plans il déciderait
sont fous de cases noires plutôt que
c'est un choix intéressant tout procès
cinq
au québec argon foule
et sur les programmes et donc comme on
parle juste avant il peut y avoir donc
décidé de rapatrier pour créer une
batterie le long tail grande allée taper
sur achète quatre fois provoquer les
affaiblissements sur le roc noir ça peut
être intéressant
s'est mis à jouer
dont 6 pouces et 2
kebede 2e ont fini le développement
prise une fois et reprend avec le pion
auquel on a une quasi dégâts pour le
cavalier on peut avoir quatre qui va
partir
ou encore une réunion intéressante
non c'est un saint crépin par ascendant
et à la perte de fouchy raynouard
il ya plus d espace pour les blancs il
ya des petites idées pour faire
attention à sa levée
si on a six qui comme un vrai problème
pour les droits sur le long terme
souvent l'impression qu'il veut tomber
et la question qu'on veut c'est qu'est
ce qu'on va comment va réagir après un
coup comme cavalier catalan on va manger
le fou et on va laisser comme ça sous un
manguier le fou aussi
les douars d'anticiper papa
cavalier seul par exemple jeunes
cavaliers est simple même en tout cas
ballet des quatre juges ces cas
là on pourquoi je pense même à cavaler
des quatre mêmes parce qu'en fait
absolument
servi au peuple est vraiment
et non ça c'est intéressant en plus
cette position avec reprend des cinq
pense pas qu'on soit vraiment france
instaure une nouveauté à avoir cette
catégorie et c'est un peu nouvelle com -
corrèze pour ceux qui sont à trouver des
originales parti qui joue pas dans la
data base en ligne j'ai aucune aucune
partie avec cette position après l est
pas énorme mais déjà ça quand même pas
d'indicateur pour dire que c'est pas
c'est pas made
principal
c'est-à-dire des banques ouest est
toujours
avoir trouvé des idées d'un manque
encore chaque pratique qui jouit des
verts bien préparé c'est impressionnant
la caméra on ira voir
où l'ado dakar est par contre si l'on
parle beaucoup de coups
ils ont pas joué beaucoup de coups
ils ont promis d'en accepter
accepté besson pourrait gagner ce match
et demi d'un bon joueur
sur ce visage et donc ses six qu'elle
choisit présent mais sans présenter sac
alors juste si tu veux rire ya un petit
piège qui marchent achètent souvent chez
les débutants
je veux montrer pour ceux qui auraient
envie de le planter
pour tron qui joue parce qu'ils jouent
des cas avec les blancs brésil
c'est après la
justice
est en fait ici généralement le meilleur
contre sept autres
plutôt que de louer 4 parce qu'en
voiture au cap il ya un bel 5 qui est
possible comme c'est possible ou saissac
et
voilà et dès que possible mais ici j'ai
rarement dit que le cou au droit le
meilleur coût fissot directement allait
récupérer le fiancé carter est ici a pas
trente six mille pour défendre l'option
est par exemple l'amour sera courbessac
qui pourrait parler d'eux parce qu'on
peut se dire bac 1 à bac 5 moi j'ai
envie de venir défendre l'euro moi je
pense qu'on peut regarder et bien mais
ça ne fait pas un bon coup du tout mais
vraiment la gare et à 4 est en fait
sur un cadre d'accueil française je l'aï
fait à six je mange en dessin qui est du
coup ils râlent vis-à-vis entre les
tours qui va être horrible du coup en
fait
assister au procès il faut jouer la
place c6
et quand on ne sait si ce n'est pas le
petit piège arrivé ici je fais apprend
bessin
ses preuves et 5 et maintenant ça me va
le prouver le gouvenement
découvert cette diagonale est ce qu il
ya de trop elle a toujours été
emprisonné et à la mairie intercepté
c'est ça juste
pour la torre parlement quand c'est un
piège que ce qui peut
on connaît pas de poil à priori donc
plutôt que trois pédiatres un conseil
donc du coup vous n'y a pas eu ça
revient sur son bien qu'ils connaissent
un
jour
là c'est vraiment du bon dans la partie
comprise
qui ces trois tonnes b6 pour de fond de
son pion
ou 2 et 6 donc encore une fois il
rappelé une puce pour les noirs mais y a
des une récompense à sion bien sûr avec
le centre un chez les blancs et puis un
avantage du développement ouais donc on
n'a que des positions en fait
intéressante a senti de l'ouverture je
trouve aujourd'hui
à l'ignorance
il y aurait pleuré
du coup on n'a qu'à les voir marc
andrieu puisqu'on a fait le tour du
masters
à l'article barton dryats
donc à 0,5 sur carte vous le rappelle le
dernier du tournoi pour l'instant c'est
très difficile pour lui il ya des noirs
aujourd'hui contre la joueuse russe
polina shuvalova qu'il mettra de
rational qui à 2516 donc bon à peu près
le bas mélo que que lui
on espère donc une réaction ou à va voir
comment ça se passe avec les normes est
parti sur une sicilienne
donc un petit dragon je réside par marc
andré a le caractère pour battre le
français au cateau il faut qu'on fout g7
f3
à gondo s'appelle assez sympa mais
l'autre le dragon ganache d'ordre qui
prépare la tacc d'autres s'y pendre des
blancs ils veulent y envoyer
des amis des deux était joué hyper
important dans le dragon et même de
manière générale dans les ouvertures et
infirmiers tôt selon mme essayer d'aller
capturer ce fou parce que c'est le le
protecteur du roi se vit-il bouche les
trous sur cases noires donc changer
c'est faux ça peut créer tout de suite
des gros danger autour du roi
et il a joué à chocs et marc andrieu
anticipé la tacc blanche pour qui
souvent caractérisé l'embargo comme jega
donc à l empêche d 4 il a peut-être
retarder son rock du gros
crachat 100 m j'ai vécu un match de plus
d'un but tout à fait ces gars tu es et
17 et finalement il y aura peut-être pas
de grands requins chez les longues
puisque à catete jouer
pourrait avoir une position un peu plus
gestion ou à dire dont la liberté rock
ont pesé mais un quart temps bien sûr
n'empêche les 5
es derrière ici pourquoi
on parle des sommes tout de suite
ce que c'est pas plus thématiques
cette foulée 5 contre ma maison avec une
fois que je devais 5 la casse et c
s'établit ainsi à une analyse comprendra
plus tard sur une case cavalièrement et
ça peut être puis revient à la
compétition
arriérés
et donc cassé je passe quoi
les précédentes c'est une idée qui peut
arriver après que saad ben harper s'est
pas vendu que ici à ses partenaires mais
30 picariello me semble que nation
comme à l'époque un bel écran 8 degrés
15 décès ça suffit pas et 6
mai pourtant à partir des 1/4 et
cavalier e st roch
le fouquet va reculer
on sait pas trop quoi faire de ce fou
hein c'est évident du coup si on
n'arrive pas à mettre en forme cateau
ont fait baisser sa voiture quand même
le pion est faible donc on va peut-être
juste faire food et ses atom autant dans
le dragon que kouchner m'envoie en est
cette fois
117 a fermé ses devoirs sont proches de
pessalle confirmé trois ans est-il celui
ci on laisse n'importe
mais non en fait une maison qu'elle a
rappelé qu'en baril si tout reste à
faire ouais mais je suis pas en moi
qu'ils engendrent un contrat pro pres
moore cch après bon c'est pas 4 n'est
pas rationnel et il a des idées à man
mais quand il n'est pas à l'aise avec un
programme entre ne trouvera pas
forcément
après bon c'est décidé toutes les
préparations des grands décideurs dans
cette partie de joueurs
h45
je veux un peu barbant au casque bleu
ciel
à voir si ces faux disparaît ok avoir
tourné au master's après on va peut-être
nous pose pour voir si on peut faire un
truc pour le son ouais alors entendre
qu'il prendrait 12 car c'est la partie
l'événement complètement courtiers
les brodequins corps et on pense que je
ne
sais pas c'est pas grand chose d'un peu
de temps alors on va revenir en arrière
mais
on était à ce qu'un budget 4 donc je
craque lamelles pour des cartes d'un
progrès car il est pro tkt pas si parker
à cette date les cinq ps un
endroit qui oubliait
des coupes tout logique pour l'instant
il a dit la finition développement à
l'état
l'amendé qu'a construit normal qu'on
soit ok mais que
le fonds avenir là et puis c'est un peu
la même préparateur incident technique
et g5 qui est logique pour mettre la
pression sur sur la diagonale
ce qui
l'est bien moins
chez sajoo il veut forcer décision ici
et s'ouvrir peut-être une colonne vous
auquel vous
poser mais qui fait sens ça n'est pas
forcément donc la menace du monde je
plonge de 5 il
a marqué sur un jeu qui va les prendre
et nous avait dit on sent que sur et sur
m6 comprenez ça pour toi un problème
pour le cavaliere
ainsi dès de prendre là
ok
à 3 était joué qu'elle
prendra donc qu'un scène qui sacrifie la
pièce a maintenant il ya peut-être là
récupéré du coup l'idée c'est ça
après la coince ça nous paraît tout
simple et les bacs des coûts on va
chasser le défenseur du canal y est ok
donc s'auto sacrifice à ce moment là
c est face à sa grande et russie joue
cavalier promesse un lycée qui va
repères de la pièce je vais essayer de
récupérer ses pions au passage les
cavaliers prend
alors est il faut aussi mettre le front
p2p paraît un petit peu la structure il
préfère garder voilà exactement sur nos
infos pour boucher les trous à prendre
position hyper complexe la paire de fou
pour les bords la position est ouverte
donc c'est une terre de foot qui peut
compter un
nez leroy cain peu affaibli le roi noir
quand on ressort de ce cavalier qu'elle
pour l'instant hors jeu c'est un gros
bordel et car c'est ici qu'a joué un
coup
quel droit un coup à jouer des cinq
web comme la coupe les sanctions échecs
passés quand même hyper
risquèrent ou mais il veut re la
collision il veut ouvrir la commission
mois patty faith que votre fort est lui
à lui a infligé un petit peu avec les
noirs ya deux jours a annoncé à son tour
et sacrifice des pions pour mieux les
limites sur le roi adverse c'est dans le
même esprit
donc laurent goury que j'en attendais
pas trop à voir max pécas reisen la
barbe blanche
bon ça c'est clair la pratique hein
c'est compliqué voire un peu trahi ce
pas je comprends qu prend la suite moi
je sais pas pourquoi bull qu'est ce
qu'il a prévu mais c'est sa nouvelle son
endroit de la bombe noire de la gamme
d'amd car je sais pas du tout internet
sera pas évident pierre états du
cavalier aussi tu veux dans mon jeu
je vous attends tu allumes est là pour
regarder à la casse provoqué le rire
est vite et pouvoir la priver reprise de
comme nat latour joue dans la colonne h
ok
c'est très très chaud
vingt quatre monnaies
curieux de voir comment ça va évoluer là
c'est en tout cas c'est intéressant on
voit le champion du monde et noir qui
est en train de
caroline il veut par contre sera varié
recourant à la fin avant de pouvoir mais
attention très bons joueurs donc ça peut
se retourner contre livre sur une partie
randy la remontée pas de la carte c'est
donc intéressant bon d'accord je crois
qu'il faisait aussi partie de l'équipe
orateurs de quatre ans
cette année je crois que 900 a créé la
travailler pour 400 dans le passé ça
c'est sûr
et donc ils se connaissent que je
connaisse apprécié
[Musique]
du coup ce tour va peut-être petite
pause
on va voir si on peut essayer de faire
quelque chose par rapport à l'école mais
ce qui est bizarre c'est que j'ai
l'impression que les qu il est il est
pas tout le temps là vient de temps en
temps
ouais alors nous avons pour voir le
problème que compte c'est ce que propose
de ne pas partir dans la seine pause
jusqu'à cuba les micros et l'angle des
caméras claudette c'est comme ça france
et puis maintenant voir une pub quand
même parce que la pub c'est la vie
et on revient quelques minutes pour être
ses devoirs de son croyez les problèmes
au
caire du coup j'ai pas coupé
il m'épate a coupé non
[Musique]
vous
il
[Musique]
à
le
oh
[Musique]
la pomme
bon
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en
on
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
je te laisse gérer donc on n'a pas
encore les points de croissance en cours
c'est en cours donc j'espère que ça va
quand même
se régler alors on est cependant partie
de 40 cents comprenant deluxe est donc
grande de félix le coup fou prend b5 ou
piratage coûte normalement nature sur la
chaîne veut pas être mauvais coups se
retrouver ça avec sa victoire d'un petit
peu
avec lui pour en fait l'essai quels
alliés agissent alors avec sa teinte
jours et
3 nuits
aux pensées
le droit à l'éducation au gvt et toi et
la tour va s'activer bien la colonne h
si le cavalier vian est celle où on va
voir
ça me paraît pas si évident quand même
que ce choix de sacrifier le pion
un peu risqué
salue pas tu arrives au meilleur des
moments en plein problèmes habituels de
son alors qu'un trio n'a rien touché par
rapport à hier donc c'est assez
mystérieux
il y avait d'un patronyme en a qui
essaient de régler en même temps mais
je vais assez sceptique on va voir
apparemment on est on
entend maintenant maintenant montant
bien est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer le
match à fond
parce que dans lequel vous confirmer que
l'on connaît bien ce n'est pas des go et
quelque soit la meilleure pour vous les
deux pour sa famille et pour moi on
savait le voile est probable aussi un
mois
alors pour savoir et parlait donc ok
essayé
mais avant de partir
du coup tout cas guardian et y réfléchir
et celles à bouger sur ward a viré
caméra il est parti en fit un ce qu'on
avait anticipé les parties se cacher
alors
merci beaucoup à tous ok
c'est déjà il ya la déco c'est une bonne
chose
tout de l'éco
genre gros est qu un petit écho un peter
& co
ouais je sais pas trop ce club pour ne
rien changer
je te retrouverai se pendre autres lots
ce qui se passe
c'est la technique de dernière minute
aussi aux frontières que rien n'était
prévu comme ça mais
bon y'a pas de raison objective que ça
marche pas correctement en tout cas
quarantaine boukary kaboré sera beach
est assis c'est que c'est une partie
complexe qui l'attend pour le coût est
pris beaucoup de risques avec les noirs
attention ce cas ce serait une petite
sensation de ce super à des contre le
dernier du tournoi
ça lui fait très mal dans sa quête des
2900 boul cela mettrait un gros coup
jack à chaque mois qui fait une nulle
hyper plein de points le pauvre
là il a une force de pouvoir partir
c'est dur c'est dur je crois que pour ne
pas perdre de points il doit faire
quelque chose comme 9 sur 13 du tournoi
et genre 9 sur 13 doit gagner un point
est loin donc c'est pas cher payé la
performance
du coup
[Musique]
l'us lawe du poisson à versailles pas
table depuis un petit moment il va
attendre qu'il revienne pour la suite de
la partie s'est produite va jouer dame b
4 c'est une question
de jours et prend le contrôle as tout
faux pas
on bat deux
fois ci les parcs disney ou
comment ou à l'asie
[Musique]
voire la barbe blanche et kaka pas du
tout aimé ce sacré de carsen après c'est
un ordinateur pas très doucement c'est
une position d'un point de vue humain
qui est très complexe donc
il ya vraiment rien ne fait a priori
rien
rien du fait du tout tous les résultats
sont possibilité ou avoir comme aux
grands des lieux
bayer a agi parce que jusqu'ici
notamment il a été plutôt très très
brouillon et imprécis en milieu de jeu
il pas choisi les bons plans
ainsi les plus inspirants rendu est
donc on peut quand même regarder ce que
donnent les chèques
à dire que le roi se cache
et donc des séries de cloud espion
nadja grillé un pion est-ce qu'on peut
pas envoyer un deuxième finale dans ce
tour un terme bon bien sûr on nous parle
bat au passage
car ce n 2 il a sûrement prévu de ceux
des clous et
parce que bon juste pour illustrer n'ont
même pas en fait j'allais dire qu'on
peut on peut aller manger ce que c'est
vraiment ils jouent comme bonne foi
reste qu'un scène j'ai l'impression il
sacrifier les pions un deuxième
peut-être pour ouvrir la ligne et
permettre un cavalier bloqueurs la tour
qui peut activer via la colonne h
c'est
position hyper compliqué
préfère qui prend les noirs ou les
blancs stuff
évidemment de prendre en main
le pion de plus et les faux
baroin qui s'est passé car c'est aussi à
moi je vous rends les têtes les noirs en
disant que j contrebande illustres tels
que les blogs je suis content car c'est
de voir la vue de tout prévoir quand
même et bien sûr mais c'est vrai que
ma
part
je préfère premiers mois encore
je pense qu'il ya peut-être pas mal de
réflexion te propose de changer de parti
qu'est ce qui t'inspire
qui as tu envie d'aller voir
alors travail avait pas eu beaucoup de
coups 1 par rapport à ce qu'on a dit
donc on va attendre un peu je pense
on prête à la croix comme va devoir
lâcher le micro non j'ai pas dans cette
branche et
non jean des rebelles ou eto'o possède
pas les maîtres donc je ne sais pas me
voilà
de retour m oui je t'entends bien à nous
autant d entre nous ça c'est la force
qui serait bien que ce soit le cas pour
tout le monde ouais tout à karaj l'insee
a très peu bougé là aussi
aller voir peut-être la partie où il ya
eu plus de
le plus jeune mouvement csip mots
coquins renard srb bat c'est
assez tendu là aussi
alors illustre budget carton de l'été
par la
g4 à chis n'avait vu ça fout des deux
prix ont été punis s'ils venaient d'y
avoir eu quatre des six penco qui est
encore dense à préparer car au nord vous
avez parlé aussi réagi immédiatement au
centre où j'ai eu 5 pour pas se prendre
lui-même e5
donc au coup assez logique
explique au camp on voyait le grand ras
qui sont
donc là
il joue
joue le beau jeu avec les pièces
blanches
dame
chance ouais normal
oui mais bien sur
l'asile
mois le canton plus là forcément
je pense que de temps en temps du même
ressort à 0,6
j'ai enlevé euros parce que je pense que
personne ne pouvait entendre du coup
c'était
way
avait plus personne tu entendais est pas
la suggestion du siècle a préféré
espérant que ce soit regardable
écoutable
et fatou on a fait quelques petits pros
nommé qu'ils soient avérées pas
forcément très inspirés puisqu'on
s'attendait à ce que
parce que justement ici pays qu il
prenne pas trop de risques avec les
blancs
qui l'a balancé g et k il a sacrifié un
pion l'effet grand roque et aux pensées
grande et lucie elle aussi serré la vis
pour essayer de stopper l'hémorragie est
pareil la pallanterie gk3 aussi et donc
il ya une position hyper chaude contre
47 donc les moins d'un mois après la
demande est là même qui
l'aï la vente iront cartel n'a pas
aux combinaisons
on y reviendra
ben écoute ses terres de bien nous
entendre on va dire que c'est
l'essentiel donc on retour à cette
partie il ya encore pas mal de courriers
roi béhanzin thématiques à chaque fois
pour contrôler quand on fait grande pour
en faire un petit coup de prophylaxie
s'enlever de cette colonne de cette
diagonale être libéré la place pour la
tour
b 7 et on a vu
évidemment caruana qui n'est pas les
rockets du côté cimetière où il y avait
la taxe qui était déjà plus qu'amorcer
et il a copié la rocqué aussi du grand
côté
maintenant
bien sûr
et j'ai cinq ans même d'ailleurs
ouais mais je n'ai pas baissé
légèrement
alors du coup h projet saccage projet 5
et le cavalier qu'elle rentre au bercail
mais c'est pas grave il va les soumettre
à une belle case angèle 6
kg vital kamerhe revenir investir 2,7 et
valier
cavaler g6 pour harmoniser les cases f4
alors j'essaie de toute beauté un peu
bas parce que sa toile ou donc moi
jamais j'aime bien doit on retenir par
en avoir ou est ce que vous demandez que
des blancs
il a joué g6 du coup pour interdit à ses
animateurs
en espace pour les cases blanches
donc ils auront une 85,3 me fallait un
jour peut-être
en se
prononçant
à blagues avec un délicat
3d karakama les 5 ou et violent
clairement il peut pas il peut pas se
permettre de laisser de laisser ces cas
c'est beaucoup trop dangereux
donc il a pris tu fous logique est ici
plus qu à jouer cavalier e 2
il ya réfléchi longtemps avant de jouer
ce coup
on imagine qu'ils essaient de se
rediriger
soit bienvenus salut same way il doit
viser certainement là peut-être la case
aussi sur la case f5 pas dit qu'il y
arrive
a dit qu'il arrive on peut imaginer car
on a juste sortir son cavalier pour
finir son développement
met une petite pression sur le pion gil
voitures tournent plus avec les noirs
soient à l'abri il est plutôt bien
regroupée va falloir comme
gossip cop justifie donc certainement il
avait travaillé en d4 alors lequel
d'après toi
plutôt le cavalier e est logique
mais ça m'a vraiment comblé
habituellement
jusqu'à 26 le point de sceller la pompe
n'a pas cette réputation jacques jambon
à la voile et non avant tout les quatre
centrales à lecavalier
il ya inclus sûrement avoir reçu les les
blancs vont réussir à trouver l'un
d'entre eux
parce qu'ils ont ces quatre îles hyper x
robin de rien et le minée par bsa
complexe
moi je suis plutôt optimiste sur les
chances de carmona ici
ouais ou à du mal elle même cette
colonne à elle est quand même importante
et peut-être ne peut se dire est ce que
c'était un film aussi bien pour les
blancs de l'avoir ouverte
vous n'arrive pas à activer notre fou
pour l'instant par ici
il a du mal à trouver son rôle dans la
position
reste compliqué comme milieu de jeu mais
pour l'instant vois pas de compensation
clair pour le pion pour le pion de son
amant
et des compensations ouais c'est ça
peut-être un premier pas avec les
tessinois on en est encore loin pour
carnac a pas encore gagné dans le
tournoi qui a fait que des nuls
bon petit coup là on a beau spectacle
trop chaud comme la braise ou là il n'a
pas lu mon coude pour la cei sont en
bois de papier les de m mais en fait
donc non on voit que
[Musique]
beaucoup réfléchi sur groupe des
cinq jouer en boîte en bois de prades
cogner chez connaît ses classiques aux
prédicats dès le 5ème à la pensée salle
s'est vidée il a accès au fichier de
stouff prague vendent en largardère ce
qui nous rejoint maintenant c'est normal
on a fait les chercher ma mon disque dur
pour retrouver un dossier que je veux
travailler
et on voit pourquoi en train de réciter
les noms s'y fier bref à se demander si
on n'a pas le sou le grand air du jura
radiant notamment c'est que le second
temps joe hardy avec le vide donc tout
cas là ça pourrait vraiment être
de ses moyens
et donc tour des reins qui a été choisie
plutôt que grand vaincu
qui est
d'après ce que tu lisais souffre et est
le principal donc c'est un peu la même
idée ce qui veux pas les mettre sur
wasquehal mondial dames peut-être qu'il
va essayer un jour de roquettes même si
pour cela il va falloir désormais rescue
et c'est pas gagné
du coup peut-être que scout tour des
incertitudes de ces fichiers justement
et il a joué tout 8 ok ils perdent en
belgique arrive et les fictions autour
d'un dossier tu l'appelles un dossier
non la balade et b4 pour défendre ce
pion c5 et donc les petits tardive qui
réfléchit on peut s'attendre à 5 à la
retrait logistique siens
pour s'ouvrir la colonna est activé la
porte ça peut être
intéressant pour le doigt le problème en
tête des deux convois c'est de résoudre
que le père de cfoot case blanche sauf
que le problème blanc est majorée par le
m le roi est bloqué en plus
moi encore une fois j'aime bien les
noirs ici
j'aime bien les noirs donc peut-être que
ton poulain
une position intéressante en peluche
rapport extrêmement un joueur qui oui la
finul dans la cas très bon mais c'est
déjà en partie décisive donc tout est
possible avec lui
bonhomme bien
d'avoir
une position vraiment dynamique
évidemment
donc fort intéressant
quel plan des blancs du coustou fla
comment on fait mais je veux trop et
j'imagine
là j'avais trois clubs européens
le genre est dans le fichier de prague
donc
a priori n'a été joué dans la base d'une
seule voix voire 14 16 hockey
alexandro lynch et le fameux
partie du contrat correspondance
n'avait hélas pas les automobilistes
dès le 4 à 5 fois
sur trois et retour des camions le
sorcier la partie vrai et après aux
logiques
dans son la danse on avait qu'internet
joué par à rapport est tout plat cette
fac leschi certainement à 5
dans la base m jaca cependant
il y avait 4 à 5 3 il
ya rien 7.5 menaçant le rapport publié
sur des points avec 3
il faut aux deux et
en actions du groupe dufour
et des pétitions pour laquelle pro la
pièce est un essai cette semaine
c'est vous et à des composera la paire
de fumay
ouais je n'aurais pas assez avec les
blondes ou non déjà des petites m avec
le clouage mais bon ça ça paraît quand
même que si on est pas si on ne connaît
pas la position c'est compliqué parce
que
le bon je pense que je pense que ce
rapport soit il connaît pas ce soir hull
mais il a promis une bonne voiture et
les gars d'appartements voler les
critiques hormis la jolie dame âgée
3,87 pas mieux il joue en fait quand
même bizarre et du coup on peut penser
que frost les palois
sont pas marsan très bien cette position
donc cette affaire une affaire de notre
ami
et grand duc à
la production notamment
à ses qualités voilà après as acquis et
qu'il joue d'ailleurs
et bien c'est difficile pour l'aéroport
les blancs
d'oeufs puis le développement
je vais convoquer nettement le même là
maintenant partenaire en inde et qui
j'avais évoqué éventuellement
mais en fait pas vraiment dans une
position non mais oui mais vous dire je
suis pas opposé mais pas avant la tv
alémanique
c'est dans une énergie mais dans les
mines et la
haie de trois manières d'être et / ou 3d
3 soit le trio qui achève une pièce est
une bonne équipe on parle de la
soie bas prix les trois là les meubles
énormes en jouets de quatre attelages
oui mais il a joué tout fait il a joué
cavalier des deux images oeuvre il
dispute la case de 4 et maintenant il
aura plus probable de pour chat aussi
potentiellement et qui menacent eux
trois peut-être deux cavaliers répartis
en 28 pour fait ici
intéressant
peut-être apprendre des 84 toi de voir
hésité entre un car
je pense que
je pense qu'il ya dedans b3 peut-être
stouff je suis perdue temps et on va
libérer si on envoyait sa santé
mais les médias polonais
bonjour intéressant vraiment c'est pas 4
donc fait avec les débats si fait que
trois pour se libérer non je sais la
prison ne sortira pas
assez intéressante aux miens et je fais
pas du coup tu fais quoi avec les blancs
3 3 peut-être
ces courageux tu fais pas le malin coin
ben moi je lance ici j'ai l'impression
d'être presque perdre en fait dans une
astroballe dans leur
style à jouer mais il a pris il appuie
salut salut rutine
way ceux des routeurs
d'abonnés
donc elle est prise
suivra en métal et donc la ja il reprend
voilà camara et reprend à tempo donc
celle là c'est le moment intéressant
qu'est ce que va jouer fine et ce qui va
jouer cet été avec le quatre mois que je
trouve très prometteuse qui dans son
style en plus et c'est logique
après le giro latran plus avaler le soir
hier
je serais surpris qu'il le joue parle
nettement
mais quelqu'un d'autre ou les noirs ici
est-ce qu'il ya d'autre part si on sait
bien peu surcoté noir au revoir aux
heureusement sans se mettre dans la tête
des noir que c'est plus est ce que c'est
plus agréable et chic et de ce côté là
pas mal de temps des tickets pour voir
un peu et bien ici j'ai l'impression
d'être pas loin d'être gagnant j'exagère
mais un
bon j'exagère à ce que j'ai un problème
avec ce fut la même position avec un
faux actif ça sera terminé
c'est quand même très prometteur je
trouve pour les noirs position
ces ballons plein le hall où les tours à
6 je suis pas mort pour ainsi cédé leur
dire
qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup ou à 6
non mais tu comprends
qu'à l'ordinaire des namurois il n'est
pas très bon
dans patton ça quand même des fois vous
voyez que la gale et des coupes qui
seront proposés seront d'ailleurs n'est
pas dans mon mandat d'élu es parti sur
ses dogmes on pouvait lire ouais ben
salah bien mais le renard et des tours 4
3 6 et découpage a fait une gaffe parce
que j'ai fait
merial est pour assister un ordinateur
sa tranquillité maria s'acoquine avec
l'idée de faire cours à 6 ans
étaient décidés à ne voir rien
finalement mais on court moins la gare
s'agit pour rappel l'arbitré prix
chapeau bas messieurs quad humainement
parlant tout 1,6 à paraître et coquilles
à envisager
maintenant j'essaie de comprendre le
medef n'est pas sur le bon je le
admettons que je passe mon histoire 124
on ne s'est pas vraiment passé le tour
je sais pas c'est les obscures ce coup
deux tours
comprenez tous que dans maintenant
c'est vrai que c'est mieux des fois de
réaliser son ordinateur si l'orateur
là je pense que même les joueurs c'est
un vrai bon c'est pas du tout dans
l'arène secours
alors que mam et les 6,6 prague retour à
cela il avait déjà réfléchi longtemps
alors de sentiment
qu'il va jouer quatre
par élimination tu peux battre un grand
chose parce que ce cavalier pas on
aimerait peut-être le recycler mais sa
part est
embêtant puisque du cavalière et cape
finir le quart temps pêche qui avait
lieu 4
pas forcément une grosse menace mais si
tu veux t'en d'aller
apparemment sa part être la menace des
blancs c'est ce père de trois enfants
appelés
après prax tu t'en souviens
sur la dernière partie d'avant-hier
c'est lui qui terminer le travail
on attendait tous qu'ils jouent avec les
blancs e5 ça nous semblait évident
c'était pareil c'était mettre deux pions
liés au centre comme sa côte à côte il a
réfléchi j'ai pas un quart d'heure il
n'a pas joué le coup tout le monde dans
le chat tout le monde voulait jouer
secousses elles semblent des voies sur
quatre il ya un coût regarder aussi ce
qu'ils valent et les toits
parce que bon
il faut calculer parce que la gécamines
et trois ans effectivement la menace de
perdre le psion donc des trois donc oui
il faut calculer et l'idée texture crise
bien sûr on prend sur échec
et là bas ça commence à sentir bon pour
le roi ou le roi blanc parce que bon si
jamais on essaie de cendres et la tour
qui va rentrer ça va être la prochaine
fois c'est une boucherie halal à granby
temps et si le four revient à boba
cavalier seul on tire le pion une
attaque ici les pièces peuvent pas
sortir ce c'est un bon dos nabli la tour
qui rentrent donc ça n'arrivera pas
donc sur ab3
des trois
salaires déjà en fait acrobatiques les
blancs dans la pression on est qu au 15e
coups bas faut qu'ils soient hyper
précis pour ne pas perdre en fait ce qui
est patron normal
si l'ouverture se passe correctement
l'équivalent de moi j'ai ici
sur abbey peut peut-être je suis teint
mathura si c'est un peu un roi gère ses
propres taxis non mais a une idée
derrière toi tous quoi je pense pas que
ce soit d'aller là bas bien ça améliore
la saison
voit ainsi j'ai quand même du mal à
contrôler unités
après moi mon ordinateur il dit pas tout
raciste c'est peut-être le tire donc
peut-être que le tien a vu trop de vue
sur commande au devin
belle histoire au moment plus de
l'argentin parce que
peut-être qu'il neige qu'il a juste bugs
ok bon écoute
je pense que prague va quand même
réfléchir
pardon ici
ou peut-être aller voir une autre partie
qu'est-ce-qui oui ce qui se passe des
choses un petit peu chaude
car ce n est ce que ça a joué qu'un
scène ça n'a pas bougé parce que cela
s'est encore une fois j'ai l'impression
de fil rouge du jour bagus un peu comme
contre rennes forest ça va être hyper
chaud mais ça va évoluer
vous serez longtemps des pales avoir
guéri j'ai dit c'est la partie la plus
excitante au juste fait un petit
jeu terme si tu ailles way s'est pas
passé grand chose pour ceux qui étaient
pas là au début on avait une petrov
visite qu'avait joué voilà
logiquement solides avec les noirs ici
on va pas avec les deux joueurs sont
très amis
à quel point ça n'aura pas acté leur
parti ne sais pas
c'est par ici c'est en train de terminer
leur développement ou cahiers à 6 le
gars y'a pas d'autres cases toute façon
on sait que voici c'est a vraiment un
coup dans cette position
où ce qu'on voudrait la faire de trous
et des galas l'anthropisation castrés
l'assaut des premiers mois
et puis la plaie avec la branche
pourrait vraiment
très faibles donc n'a pas été
envisagé donc à eux deux et là il a joué
un classement il a joué f6
alors pourquoi il a joué 6 2 août après
toi à part bien sûr contrôler ces 2 15
et peut-être d'autres résider bordel là
il est par contre chez les médecins
et ça s'entend là le 5 mai
peut-être qu'il va manger ça quoi emmené
par ses dépens
ok parce qu'on l'a vu prendre beaucoup
de risques déjà contre douba avec la
noire donc pourquoi par
la loi pas jouer j'ai cinq ans même dans
les prochains coups mais qui sait il
peut il peut nous faire mentir bon en
tout cas une potion va peut-être pas
trop s'attarder assez assez plat pour
l'instant n'a pas trop évolué s'est pas
passé grand-chose et bâtir est juste on
peut revenir vite fait sur
sur prague pour rebondir sur ce que
disait ruth en fait tout à deux
salaires un coup effectivement très
intuitif mais on avait vu que c'était
pas une bonne idée il ya un problème ou
pas c'est que cette tour elle ne peut
pas restés malheureusement à 2 elle va
se faire chasser direct par la dame et
on n'a pas de bons moyens de bons peux
pas le défendre et ou du coup on n'a pas
de bons moyens de la replacer et
finalement aide les blancs puisque cette
dame elle bloquer le développement et
les blancs ou pouvoir gagner un temps
sur un tour vous calme et de recul et
les blancs vont résoudre leurs problèmes
ici peut-être leur option de kétou donc
3 2
tours 1-2 ici
et en mer et compterait donc par d'un
bel 3
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas avoir un petit
peu notre frontière dans le challenge
m'intéresse plus aux dragons opus où
il joue un petit dragon jebet magnus
alain calmes pendant ce temps où ce
qu'on appelle un cadre des challenger
voir s'ils se passe des choses sur
l'échiquier de magnus et au mondial
prendra parce que c'est là où
où l'action est la plus intéressante on
en est et où sur marc-andré à
on en est des lycées
foulée il habille son fonds 17
et du coup f4 été joués bond intéressant
elle change de structure là
elle était solide jusqu'ici elle
contrôlait les cases et finalement la
joueuse russe f4 qui est plus agressive
1 pour essayer d'avoir des percées
ensuite au centre
aurait peut-être qui
il a eu peur non j'ai à dire son
cavalier peut toujours ressortir à chis
peut-être qu'il s'est dit qu'il était au
vu
du coût aussi d'eric son cavalier serait
mal placé
on peut comprendre à perdre trois pays
on était quand même assez moche ouais on
saisit que payet s'est dit plus baladé
et dopu un jeu trouvera pour un petit
coup prophylactique pour enfin rock et
tranquillement sans se faire embêter
moi je me serais attendu peut-être des
fois du h4 cavalier seul dans cette
position donc il ya un trou ici
mais il a décidé de rockets mark andriat
shuvalova on a fait de même
ils échangeront des caps ont libéré la
place au bourg le fou
ça souvent valable dans les partir des
fois on sait pas ne trouve pas de casque
pour ses pièces mais il faut
enlever une pour donner l'accès à
l'autre ça arrive assez régulièrement
ici c'est ce qu'il a choisi celle ci
s'il veut taper sur ce pion
et du coup se trouvent tant parlé plus
tôt tu aimais pas trop finalement ce fut
un choc était thématiques mais vu
l'évolution de la partie on va dire qu'à
mieux quand les blancs ici d'attaqué
qu'il y en ad rock blues est annoncée à
d'affaiblissement parce que regarder
ya cette diagonale toujours donc
l'option eps vii est un peu faible et le
pion g6 du coup est défendu par les
puristes qui est cloué et david on a ce
pion l'aïe qui défend et ici ça peut
créer vraiment des idées à laquelle ces
requins la dame qui arrive
j'ai peur qu'il soit encore dans une
position un peu compliqué un bar cambria
dès la sortie de l'ouverture
c'est la vraie
gouvernement pour qu'il est vraiment
si un jour on m'a demandé ma benz a
prolongé d'un mois des menaces et 1,36
et fait tout et pour
tout
elle sera majorée pas sa place
mais
est ici c'est clairement battant on
aimerait reculer un peu comme déjà parlé
plusieurs fois dans différents live
souvent reculer le pion est le meilleur
coup s'il était autorisé dans certaines
positions
f5 alors peut-être mal préparée dans
défendent le pion de l'arctique à la
joueuse là bas on va aller à la partie
parce que c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé elle a ramené sa dernière pièce en
action on voit qu'elle joue de manière
hyper naturel lassé de voir derrière ses
pions au centre toutes les pièces sont
développées de manière
logique sur des cases saine et la plus d
espace
faudra jouer qu'il y ait des sept
hommes c'est qu'ici je conviens il va
déjà être un peu à court de deux coups
avec les noirs c'est dur de trouver une
idée on ne peut pas
peut pas avancer les pions au centre ce
que bath est trop faible
besson avec sa double et pour autre
chose
si j'ai raison que c'est moi la perdre
peut-être que j'exagère mais bon c'est
dur prévient ses moindres recoins
des blancs les blesse je voudrais c'est
à dire très dures tour pour les noirs à
jouer en pratique ça il a joué sa ville
et y avait envoyées et reçues en temps
c'est exactement ce qu'on dira elle met
la pression
sur les faiblesses noir ml clément
malades 6 et je pourrai pas être licite
moi même parce que je
vois la voix propose
aux causes c'est dur de prendre un bon
tu fais quoi avec les doigts pas dire
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya quasiment
lors qu'elle est reprise bon ça va être
d'ailleurs l'idée de marc andré ac
on met un cavalier là mais non tu
walsh 7 propose
7 ici oui parce que wall-e jeunes à
défaut
j'en profites tu as perdu attend
peut-être noms
des dates des bananes peut-être par là
mais même au même faire un échec
de la mission d et noir se défendre et
on
regardait recettes j'avais cet éphèbe le
même noyau re-découvrir n'ai
pas réussi ce
marché il faudrait que la dame puisse
faire un échec justement pour dévier le
roi de la protection du gâteau donc là
ça marche pas exactement comme tu dis
mais on n'est pas loin déjà de pouvoir
le faire marcher c'est dans l'air quoi
donc ici vous voudrez trouver un coup un
coup pertinent avec les blancs mais j'ai
pas notre flair déjà nous dit qu'on a
l'impression d'être pas loin d'avoir
déjà un gain
de près sur les problématiques admettons
prison
lacava lieux de l'avalanche et
tu veux ouais je ramenais la dernière
pièce n'aboutit vise pas le roi le roi
noir et ses alentours
et problème c'est que les doigts ils ne
peuvent rien faire ou bête on ya
peut-être encore quatre
échecs cavalia s'ils
perdent c'est un travail de funambule
pour les noirs de
le garder un semblant d'équilibré scié
bref ça qui réfléchit
ouais bon j'ai peur que ce soit pas
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
que notre petit français sortent la tête
de l'eau alors que propose de retourner
chez magnus puisque j'ai vu jaguar qu'il
avait joué en quoi la caméra
oui pollution ok quand dsk décidé de pas
prendre l'option alors c'est la
tentation
d'un repaire du chouf
ça faisait longtemps adopté doit
repayer à son forfait avec son téléphone
et l'envoie là
voilà tu recharger
ça va bien devrait réussir à coïncider
avec les pauses mais
du coup
j'ai remis car c'est qu'il ya eu une
évolution et une évolution ou à 4
way on en était resté ici
donc il apprit qu on se bat chaque point
et fuite voyez eu de coups mais un coup
en fait qu'on n'avait pas du tout
envisagé c'est intéressant il a peint
fait cet échec
le rendez lui s'il a joué fois car
beaucoup n'avaient pas envisagé mais qui
peut faire sens par rapport à la défense
du pion
mais là où c'est quand même une décision
responsable c'est qu'il laisse la
possibilité à kars end des 4
leaders car c'est moi je pense qu'il
était très heureux de jouer ce coup là
encore ça décale en bas de la rue bloco
effet beaucoup
donc
pas convaincu comme sa première vue de
la décision de granby du sme
et encore
oui oui mais en fait ils auraient ils
auraient pu avoir la même c'est à dire
que peut-être sans laisser des 4
[Musique]
watts tu manges en est
oui oui c'est pour ça qu'ils essaient de
ghadames bk prophète
après cette manoeuvre était peut-être
pas si facile à trouver
oui là il a considéré que ça c'était
dangereux mais c'est vrai que c'est trop
pratique vous il ya deux pions puces
pour les blancs deux pions passés liés
malgré tout mais
bon
non non c'est pas clair du tout c'est
bien sûr
ça peut faire peur effectivement
ça peut faire alors du coup il a choisi
peut-être une voie plus safe eh bien
peut-être ne sait pas dans l soula sous
la veste il a hélas la chemise brodée
lui est ce que ça va lui porter chance
d'avoir un jeu pas si l'avenir la
poubelle son pull mais on va voir où
agathe et doux car c'est novak a joués
des 4
et bat toujours une position à double
tour jour-là il viendrait ramener son
canadiens ont eu un peu de mal à
il a peut-être passer par la scam à lire
c'est sûr bon la prochaine fois
occupation du champion du monde ici
voilà
donc ça sera bon de voir le roi y avoir
droit peut-être qu'on peut s'imaginer
audition avec ge descente
chez sa kawa gers est géré par d'âge
tapant fermement certains rappeurs d'âge
cadet peut-être mettre soi-même l'atome
est pas un peu long une position qui
sans vraiment des sentiers battus un
atypique avec des rois a bizarrement
placée un pion de plus pour les blancs
et des gants même des compensations
ok je vois bien quand même magnus et un
petit à petit outplay son adversaire ici
c'est pas parce que ce soir orientale et
tu vois la partie qu'on a eue le mât
même religion on a même une ouverture
dans des lieux propres prochain
après l'ouverture et bien il avait joué
autour de 3
et là j'ai un peu peur que j'arrive un
peu le même pas autre chose ici un an
des listes où la nature est une
tradition nous savons
qu'on va voir un père et un fils et
trois mois mais
vers la kaaba 12/07/2010 à la logique et
24 pour les blancs peut-être
fait c'est toujours la colonne est fier
aux grands comptes en battant à
sécuriser le pion ces deux donc tu
libères un peu ta dam être cas tu essayé
de miner je pense clairement
mois typiquement je jouerai je pense du
roi bien et j'essaierai de faire de jeu
pour être quatre messieurs
c'est très chaud peut-être qu'il a envie
d'attendre par exemple regard que
quelques cavaliers bouche pour jouer aux
cartes pour éviter de se prendre un
cavalier carrier nouveau 3 ou à la peine
de vous faire des petits coups utile
prophylactique comme roi bien phu b3 et
carine zanella pas forcément grand chose
d'autre à faire que cavalier là et
maintenant voyez africa
alors prendre vraiment extra terrestre à
allah ou yes men of
croyable
incroyable il avait digne des rois grdf
que
qu'est ce que c'est que ce qu'on avait
coulé fe cachette
auraient ensemble vous
croyez le
en fait c'est toute l'équipe derrière
derrière pai a pas de pensée
alors wife fuite on n'a pas dû arriver
sur un jeu de rôle à ben sahar où elle
fut
extrait
l'idée souffre de voir la fuite s'est
déjà on est vite dans la position il y
avait toujours ce thème deux fois çi ça
avec des menaces de matt
cooke a priori ça ne l'est pas
dramatique et toujours du kayak du g6
une telle qu'il voulait pas ça fait bien
sûr cases noires mais qu'il a pu s'en
fout de cases noires
c'est une des raisons j'ai cherché
pourquoi l'actuel fuite je vois pas trop
où un stand autres et le zodiaque le
ganil attendant soulagement il menace
mais voilà c'est tout à la réponse ils
menacent h6 pour gagner la paire de flou
mais avec à petit les plus courts ce
qu'il faut regarder en face aux ducs
ouvre la campagne au cadre doit pas être
possible cadets et blanc montrant
qu'elle va les prendre car la saga une
pièce juste radama mauvais si elle mange
le coup derrière
sagan moment et du coup on se croirait
matériaux 4 mai
3,6 je pense quand même ouais et en fait
quand tu mangeras en d4 mal du
foot mon frère mais n'empêche qu'il faut
qu'il va falloir manger
mais cessons jamais de dh si ça t'as
raison mon mieux pour montrer est ce
qu'un sacrifice comme ça
c'est que la dame à la double attaque
tout seul voilà où partent à kaihori sap
est suffisant puisque chaque âge et
pierre daudelin
donc donc non alors ça change quand les
poires avec wahaha suit le demandeur ou
toulon m'échappe je pense qu'en fait ils
ramènent le roi quand même sur cbs et
puis après ils vont actuellement pour la
ramener à la normale le roi
s'est il veut être plus mal au ventre là
je pense oui lors du pouvoir regarde
c'est que peut-être que
ya peut-être des idées
ici donc admettons le 3 sur un chiffre
était décidé d'acheter ici
c'est le royaume suite ok j'ai plutôt
fait relâche à londres pour vous montrer
c'est l'idée de jouer h quatre cas cette
thématique il ya un vis-à-vis dans la
colonne h 10 au bas si tu manges clos
rouge et derrière je vais gagner ton
cavaliers donc là le roi noir va se
retrouver complètement dans les
coronaires donc en fait tu fais rouages
suite à chis ne marche pas
concrètement non à cause de la carte
j'ai l'impression
baye assane diagne peut-être qui la
dérange et je pense que c'est la raison
de la menace avait les moindres alors
que là on peut du coup après roy et puis
là rarement devant notre site
web alors que dans la partie wheadon sur
roya fuite on peut quand même regarder
ce que est ce que h4 est encore possible
ben là je pose justement jeu et on
devrait pouvoir s'abriter
au revoir que la barbe blanche aime bien
les bleus ici et donc
ouais ça va pas être humain mais bon
derrière cette case
ok ça soit mais bien sûr que la piètre
en russie soit
vois pas du tout suffisant c'est même
moi même que les blancs et davantage
dans cette position on voit qu'il ya un
peu de contre jeunes mais de là à dire
que les noirs sont dale sa sommes pas
évident d'un produit mais je doute que
un rapport il est capable
voilà on va voir on va voir si si le 3
est joué c'est pas un certain
est d'ailleurs une suggestion
surtout pourquoi pas adressé deux cases
c'est de dire bah si tu pensé maintenant
parce que la prison façon tu as droit de
la faire que maintenant après déjà tu
pourras plus beau on souhaitait pas
l'idée des noirs de prendre we made you
tube six escales et
alors c'est bon mais en deux mois aux
parents des trois ya peut-être du tour à
trois attention je ne vois le courage
qui m est désagréable peut-être
avec avalanche 5-2 d'entraînement on va
les premiers fous de leur mieux vaut
deux
c'est sûr à d'apprendre ça
[Musique]
mais en fait ça tirait combattre ça m'a
l'air moins forte avant parce que
les blancs ont revendiqué un blocus que
le centre a reçu 2,4 à berchem qu'il
faudra que tu passes une session avec
mon poulain travaillé le jeu au centre
sur les pions là parce que ça fait deux
parties de suite que je vous parle
beaucoup
4 c'était quand même hyper prometteurs
ont identifié un problème chez les
blancs au fait c'est vraiment ce roi cas
du mal à beaucoup de balles à s'abriter
à cause du développement du fou qui
étaient bloqués dont on joue contre quoi
on joue le contre pour le bloquer
et au lieu de jouer contre
sabah et la joie un coup
un petit peu j'en sais un peu snob royal
fit corp of china
bien sûr il ya eu d'idées mais c'était
trop pris la tête alors que la
simplicité des plus efficaces plus
direct
on va avoir la position reste bien sûr
très complexe mais
peut-être s'il a voulu trop en faire
explique droit il fit
voir ce qui se passe sur je voyais on va
voir ce que joue un rapport on peut
supposer qu'il a plusieurs déceptions
quand même
vachement
bien ingrate arriver quand même beaucoup
qui libère son four à ici la balle choix
la ja pas quelle autre coup candidat
mais bros a dit cet été alors pour les
droits réels
mais à part trois ou quatre femmes
ont montré leur
profonde réflexion je ne mets pas la
partie de confort est parce que c est
c'est parti en choeur tous les titres tu
as raison c'est chaud chaud chaud
détentrice de parcours fait voici ma vie
est derrière ça va on avait déjà senti
peut-être que que ça va faire une partie
coulon était resté à d'un pas ici je
croyais qu'elle et ses sols où il avait
décidé de donner son fou de cases noires
et il ya vu ses trois d'avoir eu ces
sites et de batterie
est
[Musique]
logique il devrait jouer un jour le
compte spécial
donc arriver car on avait décrypté croix
dans le cou aux molex quelle sera la
réponse de loin surprise des dégâts et
leur magie sous des seize donc en gros
il bouge ton trou je veux garder sa
paire de faux c'est ça et en fait de
bayrou 7 5 et attention que ses seins
sagan à une pièce parce que son père
mais les bouger bajolet c4 avec avec
pour chacun il menace ou de temps donc
évidemment votre foi ainsi date du sart
mais il s'est dit ok je m'en fous moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est au roi
une petite astuce toof on peut voir
c'est que sur ces sommes par exemple
si besoin pour à intercaler un fou ces
deux communes astra maths ça deviendra
la priorité est le temps que les noirs
par le maton pourra bouger le cavalier
et il y aura plus de fourchette puisque
ce fou je fus banon se prononcer dès
qu'il aura disparu saison mais les
petites astuces pour ne pas perdre deux
pièces merci c'est la partie du c5
les banques restent ils lui l'est pas
dans les petites astuces il est dans le
ragot bonito depuis le début du tournoi
il veut tout envoyer et là il a joué peu
6 donc en dix ans et je te mets toute
emprise des bruits temps avec ça
et ses suivants pour ça qu'on aime bien
sûr de joueurs parce que mais devant son
compte en fait de se rentrer dedans
comme ça ouais et a aidé à nous ce qu'on
aime bien voir un spectacle franchement
c'est vraiment joli quand même beau
alors là il faut évidemment voir ce qui
se passera jamais dimanche aux cavaliers
ok j'ai une carte assez rare ça sur
sarthe des liens sur bouger le fou et je
sais pas disons d'un pro 17 - pris dans
un scandale éclate
bon lors d une position
le fou le fou à cet électeur banlieue
est regardé la structure de pions et
symétriques mais les pièces mineurs des
blonds sont supérieures saxo cavalli il
a axé la grand poste où il va chasser la
dame fou il a une diagonale intéressante
lui il est plutôt passif est lui aussi
donc je serai un léger plus blanc
du coup ici
perdu deux points ce qui serait pourtant
il avait traversé toute l'europe on a
parlé plus tôt bestar nuit ce nombre a
donc gagné 6 on aurait pu prendre un
way presse prend la responsable réfuter
un parent elles feront carrière logique
parce qu'on mange un pion déjà gratuits
psy les défendent yeux et on réitère
toute nos menaces
mais elle a des petits problèmes de
menaces justement de match sur le pion
achètent ils g5 et après cavaler points
c'est ce qui pourrait pas une course
avec la cour et la demande exactement
avec le temps que mon par le bas donc je
sais pas par geci sous par cavalli g6
pour apprendre qu'il éprouve aussi c'est
la pièce qui était reprise va finalement
elle se libère et elle fait une
fourchette
la vague et du matériel avec les blancs
on a mangé la récupération et on va
gagner la qualité aussi à lui qui tombe
derrière c'est catastrophique
du coup on n'est pas conseillée il a
également récemment beaucoup en
1717 stocks sont affaissées sauf qu'en
france plus
tôt pour envisager la dernière remise
des fous prend ils font trop bas on a la
même chose avant c'est la même histoire
c'est pareil très important les
cavaliers contrôler cette case donc ya
pas deux fois de cinq
réseaux urbains pareil on parle on parle
battait derrière mouscron cavaliers en
russie c'est terminé
donc soit 58,6 millions of a opté pour
wii
donc seuls 6,5 un joli coup déjà un joli
coude
de bong forest le foie recul et donc
comme tu es d'idées en u18
qui défont
et maintenant d'ailleurs quoi on n'a eu
qu'à rallier g5 où il continuera même
idée il envoie imeda ce match
et ici j'imagine 25 jours pour parer le
mat bloc ou ferment cette diagonale qui
était si si dangereuse
sur gecina match 3
enfin c'était compliqué et puis on dit
bon bah alors comment tu résultats
problème attention
donc sur sur l'apprenti le cavalier noir
vous pourquoi cavalier seul
bonne question alors cavaillès est bon
en fait déjà ici comme je vous dis dans
cette situation vous qu'il fasse
attention à ces pièces là il a des
problèmes
il ya beaucoup de menaces d'ong qui
trouvent un moyen peu acrobatique d'un
bond ya donc à l'alliance est bon la
dague la dame il crée une priorité il se
dit que sur fou prend qu est le premier
cours ou envisagées
il va libérer la case 6 5 qui est
vraiment le thème de toutes ces
tactiques depuis tout à l'heure à chaque
fois d'amener un cavalier là
pour donc sauvé sa pièce qui attaquait
en gagnant un temps sur la dame s'est
pas être béton dame bouge
mais même là tu passais pas évident
parce qu'ils se retrouvaient à sacrifier
un pion mais il faut quand même par et
ses cartes il a pu pousser de cette
fois-ci
peut-être et 18 kg sérique d'amh h3 ont
attaqué la tour et sur ces quatre
j'imagine peut-être mais c'est bien
d'être une menace tous moi j'avais plage
je suis content
on peut bouger le cavalier mais ces
quatre n'est plus une menace ici grâce
bouclage
est juste on va juste faux bond aux
pieds
tout son idée elle est vraiment en fait
pour simplifier sur la libération de la
case e6
vous y mettre un cavalier
et du coup mamediarov tu es bien qu'il
est il a pris avec sa tour
ça c'est hyper bien joué de sa part en
disant je garde tout au bout fou et donc
bâton idée d'aller 11,6 ça n'arrivera
pas
et on triple problème là bas il est
toujours là et bano comment tu ne résout
alors certes pour l'instant les blu ray
une qualité pour un pion d'ailleurs
c'est la suite de la partie vous mangez
second pion mais ils se prennent le c4
ils se prennent le sait car il n'avait
pas le choix en même temps et du coup
d'un point de vue matériel va se
retrouver avec deux fourches pause
contre tours olympio
il ya eu tous ces cas là pas le choix il
y donne accès ce qui est perdu toute
rupture au passage il aurait pu theresa
may ça changeait rien ça change rien ça
pourrait même si
l'attaqué est de toute façon
il va être forcément par le faut afin de
la région qui ont donc dans la partie et
les problèmes sac
est ici il a repris donc il va reprendre
il verra retroussé 4 et on va voir cette
position
alors ça fait donc une tour pour à de
fou une tour est un pion pour deux
fronts
ouverts tout verdict ici bas pour moi
c'est ça va être bien moins je pense ça
va être bien réelle alors qu annonce la
couleur
wagane large il mêle par emplacement
france pour gagner pour le secteur en
fait de fou c'est quand même très très
fort bien meilleure une tour
d' a par exemple déjà décidé 3 contre 1
à 100 bref pour en bloquer la colonne
des
et un autre qui veulent mettre les gazs
noir france et sa demande et une
décision peut-être c'est le français le
pion à 5 irina tableau c'est à se
demander ce qu'ils vont s'activer dans
l'hérault doit renaître pour 1,5
le rouleur de renard les vraiment
sécurité pas que les collections la
question
et je pense que les fonds n'arrivent pas
à
cette peau blanche allemand c'est être
honoré ici je pense que ça serait
vraiment terminée parce qu'on fait
exactement ce que tu dis on irait m
infondées 3 et là ça serait la fin comme
si la position aussi ouverte indique
c'est quand même un très bon signe pour
l'expression des fous cette fable en
bout qui doivent se montrer je pense
extrêmement
j'allais dire pas le bon adjectif mais
direct ils peuvent pas du tout se
permettre d'attendre un petit peu parce
que si les noirs consolide là ça va être
terminé en quelques cours il ya sinon ça
sera vraiment très difficile qui
s'activent en fait très très vite les
blu ray actuels retour un peu de jeu
c'est leur seule chance donc encore s il
doit réfléchir à ça est ce que vous
imaginez non mais c'est pas les choses
comme ça peut-être que si les tours
commence à gagner des temps il peut y
avoir des du contre je pas
donc on va voir on va voir comment il
son sort là ce sont des coups forts
c'est donc
en ce moment où en arriver là assez vite
là et réfléchie certaines normes mois
avec les boys d'appel très content de la
tournure et pour le coup il n'y a aucun
hyper bien joué tactiquement la l'arrêt
volontaire il a réfuté
un message dans la boîte
mais j'ai chez moi je suis moi j'ai pas
du tout pourquoi rue non je pense que je
sais pas si cai skype lecteurs un
problème d'échiquier
douchez ou à seddouk aventure star soir
transmission mais je pense pas
voilà est reparti avec en plus le samu
mois accélérant petite pause il revient
du coup et pourrait bouder partie
spectaculaire pour le coup lors d'un
grand défilé aujourd'hui bonne forest ma
mère d'après la zonda c'est très très
chaud sur beaucoup d'échiquier donc vous
vous dire dans quelques minutes
[Musique]
il
et
[Musique]
le
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est de retour donc sur grande et luce
et quinzaine
bien les séparaient cavaliers avec 7 on
l'avait prédit évidemment cet échec qui
apparemment
l'ordinateur et faudra donc sous betoya
set ça aurait effectivement c'est quoi
ton du de magnus et donc il choisit
maintenant de faire cet échec grande et
luce alors qu'il va peut-être pu le
faire qu'on le traite encore des 5 et
créent des problèmes tactiques
sûrement dans quelle idée de faire les
chèques maintenant puisque autant tout à
l'heure
pour revenir un petit peu en arrière
quand on était ici
[Musique]
autant ici avait une idée c'était de de
croo espion pour le gagner
autant imposition actuelle le danube et
catéchèse
à première vue je vois pas l'idée km
pour moi j'évite ce que toi
tu comprends où il veut en venir avec
son dame becache que l'on était plutôt
partie sur des robes
des phases essaie de faire un marché
peinant à ouvrir la colonne jouer sur ce
roi
donc si je te la gauche comprend pas
trop ce court article ordinateur voit la
barre noire qui nous confirme c'est a
priori pas le bon coup pour les blancs
qui a pourtant pris beaucoup de temps
accordé de licence pour le jouer tu vas
trop techno dans cette partie et ça
confirme aussi depuis la bulle autour de
vous rappeler à 0,5 sur quatre il y
avait plutôt des bonnes positions aux
sorties des ouvertures et en milieu de
jeu il a choisi des mauvais plans et
après tu es mauvais chemin et s'est
égaré à chaque fois et j'ai l'impression
que la has et bis repetita pour le genre
suédois parce que
voilà on pensait que roy bennett quatre
membres on avait un
timbre clair que la colonne ère étape
équipe en droit adam b4 marchande tu
peux ranger aux tournées à bloquer le
cas mais les coups et je comprends pas
ce qu'il veut faire et sa dame joue
finalement écoulé rivaux les plus hauts
revenus et prix du beau jeu au caire ni
maintenant le responsable
avec les plans pas trop mal mais tous je
fais un rabais du coup quelqu'un me
contre 6 me voilà
de retour à troyes est étrange que ce
roi
pour des clous et 20 tranquillement
mis en jeu par angers ça qu'on fait avec
respect du droit
du coup on fait quoi pour défendre ce
qu'ils ont fait tour des trois points
forts
c'est ça que ça a pas l'air terrible
déjà lors des mariages godard miss île
am i like complexe qu'il est là membres
sur ce thème deux fois 6 1 qui peu
d'entre eux
en fait déjà ça devient compliqué de
dépendre le kurde
car aussi probablement des saints on a
raté des fouilles si sarah calculer
quand même ce qui a peut-être d'un
procès deux échecs moi c'est très chaud
ça à froid 6 pts est peut-être que il ya
des idées comme ça
d'un procédé peut-être pas un bon coup
parce que finalement certes on mange un
pion mais derrière on va se prendre un
tour c'est un
qui va nous faire très mal donc un style
plutôt interdit et on prend le temps
passe vite et je prends le 4
je crois qu'avec la dame du quoi bon
franchement prendre option de 80 mais
directement hockey d'avoir la preuve
c'est que d'un processus pas une menace
un intrus faire [ __ ] ces pages il faut
prendre conscience
que l'on veut trop mais non mais juste
simplement en parlant de
ça donne en matériel dan qualité de mots
avec les doigts ou un pion et de ses
narines un budget 24
les et cinq cantons pratiquent moins
maintenant il est hyper cei le cas il
est ouvert et j'ai tout le monde qui est
actif et ton trou en moto c'est une
poubelle et la pollution et permet
donc c'est intéressant
mais dire qu'on pouvoir avoir le ok
les gars n y réfléchissez donc et
réfléchit à l'affiché adams et 5 passes
qu'il a pas d'autre option il ya pas
bêtes seront 8 il n'y a pas joué à tempo
ici donc dame saissac échanges et ben
non je suis débile viadom en baisse est
donc j'ai pas quoi ils réfléchiront pet
à cavaliers des 6 ou d'amd six
cavaliers des 6
et à peut-être du foot pro des câbles on
voit que l'abarth et affolait
jouer sur le clonage
et
ouais ça c'est vrai qu'on sent que ça va
être très dangereux pour 1,5 leroy plein
milieu de l'échiquier là il
reste complexe
et dames d'assises du coup beaucoup ici
méritent jordan vaisselle ou pas en fait
qu'un celle qui a pris beaucoup de temps
bon sur moi et prières et rihanna suit
en fait
il a pris beaucoup de temps pour je
crois j'ai vite au final donc qui semble
être le seul coup on a reperdu souffre
qui pourtant a priori venez de
de remettre du parfait dans son
téléphone à payer de retour
il faut mettre une petite pièce dans la
machine à chaque fois pour que la
musique de toute sorte de sa bouche et
donc magnus arc a fini par l'orangé
puisqu'on peut être par élimination
regarde toutes les autres options basse
a perdu une pièce
il ya peut-être d'un bus est aussi même
pas envisageable
bonjour j'habite pas loin mais
moi j'ai lu depuis le bon coin que le
monde roule maintenant on va voir l'idée
de nils parce que y en avait du mal à
comprendre ceux d'amd 4
on va voir comment elle ne voulait plus
logique un an son cadet vis-à-vis on
était en convoi il peut aussi si je vais
t'en 2 pour libérer son faux de la
défense du pion ces deux
en tout cas perspectives de magnus qui
ont quelques coups déjà
se sont améliorées elles soient
améliorées clairement
ça pourrait faire une partie décisive
est ce que tu pourrais pas d'avoir une
petite fille avec son fameux roi et puis
là-bas il a il a quand même réussi à
installer par ou alors
il a quand même réussi à enseigner un
tour au des trois récents on en était à
bahia a joué
trois fuites d'eau mais rien pour vous
attendez vraiment eu trois ou quatre
buts dans ce but que de joueurs qui leur
but c'est qu'on ne trouve aucun de leurs
coûts jusqu'à la fin de la partie jeu
possible
madame p3 sa logique aussi l'impression
a présenté d'autres
et aussi se garde aussi le g3
finir développement
mais axis et bien sûr des foules ou
de la revue la casse pour le fou en fait
est vrai que j'ai cinq projets de
croissance pourrait trouver pour les
noirs au style du tout
il ya quelques les noirs à condition
comme dit vendredi la rencontre casement
et
chanteuse noire avant des 6-7 7-6 en
gestion et en voir un cavalier
mais même si jamais un jour je
voulais faire et bien sûr le red wagon
des six donc c'est pas facile sur
quasiment c'est pour ça que richard
rapport a décidé de jouer dans b3 et la
case et je crois pour le fou et et du
coup on compense comprends mieux
non il ya eu il ya eu la
cote de jouer en fait j'ai l'impression
qu'il faudrait que je peux que je me
coupe à chaque fois que tu parles pour
que tu es peut-être moins d'écho mais ce
qui n'est pas normal
ouais bon
mais en voyant les comptes coupe ton
comment je parle
évidemment de quoi le centre est sous
toit ou l'inversé en fait je te coupe ya
pas d coûte tout court du coup
quand tu quand tu parles pas toi
qu'est bon on a compris un truc ce faire
pas forcément vous aider tant que ça
mais
je vais réfléchir donc juste pour
revenir la partie dont il a joué ce
fameux e 4 qu'on apporte de tous prague
y est ça y est a décidé de jouer trois
rapports et donc des trois qui a
fermeture
qui paraît logique un des trois là oui
mais moi j'ai les boules le groupe pour
bloquer le football on
est maladroit était joué donc on imagine
que les blancs peut-être en vue de
charge et 4g 2
je passais l'idée aurait demandé à sa
poitrine parce qu'on a commandes en ont
envie de voir un mauvais coiffe noire le
mouvement
comment pourrais continuer ici parce que
la personne quand même pas facile est
quelqu'un de plus pour les blancs et le
cul en capcir emprise ce qui veut dire
quand je ne peux pas me gave aller au
sein parce qu'il y aurait ou a le bon
faire l'année prend le cadre d'un geste
us mais blair je pense une solution mais
c'est parfaite qu'il avait pas
d'ambiance michael marsh et
effectivement
je te laisse un sale goût
donc mon gars français hyper intéressant
je pense qu'on laisse
ce qui est drôle c'est qu'elles
attendent à l'anglais d'un nouvel aréna
pour vos trois génisses
roi qui croît de 8 mai avait dépassé pas
d'entendre une nouvelle roi voilà huit
dans le transport des mois et n'ont pas
grand-chose à faire la location de votre
ligne et à améliorer la position
mais j'ai quatre étaient tous des blancs
et est en tout cas très intéressant g4
avec projet de la tribune on surnomme
rupture avec quatre
parties vraiment
mais je continue à bien aimer les noirs
intime
malgré le point noir des pieds noirs
sont bien placés pendant le footing pas
encore sorti
mais je pense que j'ai quatre couples
qui a empêché rhin on pourra pas
empêcher g41 pour longtemps peut-être
plus tôt fille siens
voilà comment dire sombre sûrement pas
des petites plantes et les gens doivent
deviner ce que tu dis
vraiment il en branle ok
échos disparaît
non mais là là je pense pas qu'ils
définissent pas puisque jérémy comme
c'était
ça rien
jamais je continue à bien aimer les
noirs dans l'opposition même si j'ai
quatre on va arriver dakar tournant je
vais tellement ouverte par couple
un jour un petit baiser
comme on dit c'est trop compliqué c'est
plus j'essaie de cliquer quand tu parles
après déclic et quand moi je parle mais
assez une trop grosse gymnastique du
cerveau avec la partie adaptant au
complexe
ok positions complexes en off
finalement craqué peut-être un peu raté
sa chance
voilà
maintenant
moins bonne ça peut compliquer plus par
an mais
[Musique]
ça fait piller des maisons des ces
personnes une pour voir si vous montre
de leur corps de son
[Musique]
père souffre raconte l'histoire
d'un père castor est ce qui si vous nous
entendez ou pas
suspense ce que est ce que casque et
c'est mieux
sami casqués est ce que c'est le stream
eu et
charlie sheen cantine bref à reims trop
mou et un droit la lecture sur les
lèvres est intéressant d'en bas béchir
donc on nous dit rien on va continuer
comme ça peut-être on parle dans le vent
et d'histoire oui c'est mieux bon bah
écoutez si c'est mieux je vais essayer
de garder un casque pour l'instant vous
allez me dire si ça confirme sur le sur
le long terme d au pire de kabylie où
vous lisez soyez lesamis
particules bien poisson stouff date il
peut même être de nous faire un thé très
fort un tyson pour me mais je pense que
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus intéressant
d'avoir une analyse me mets de souffle
et des crues de ces ce choix plutôt que
de l'écouter en fait
je serais beaucoup plus je suis ce goût
plus à bourg en bresse que beaucoup plus
un bac je
[Musique]
vais essayer pas si c'est mieux vas-y
yes bon est ce que tu peux changer de
parti on
va voir quoi jeter un coup d'oeil gb 4
apporte ton rock il va bien
c'est très intéressant d'avoir exhibé un
coup dur oui puis on avait vu que
kavanagh était
était dans une position intéressante au
ciel
et choix s'avérait très chaud
j'ai l'impression moi c'est pas à jour
donc je vais la partie de la digue et je
veux récupérer
voit ça qu'à la ligue 2 j'ai passé un
problème pièces comme sur cette partie
mais
bon moi j'ai un
mois j'ai
un peu plat moi je suis le cac avait eu
deux
mois gb 4 il ya eu ces prend le métro en
pas semble clair tu cries nous a dit je
baisse autre recommence pour leur parle
ça change
les cavaliers cadre d'un v6 faut croire
au 22e coup encore délicate c'est la
première fois qu'elle va j'espère que
c'est bon tout cas niveau sont à une
heure du conte à quand un problème est
réglé il faut bien y en a d'autres qui
se porte on ajuste l'échiquier
de caro nome j'ai pas du coup je sais
pas pourquoi
renoncer
à saillé
voilà c'est réapparu maintenant il est
trop basse tout
c'est moi qui suis trop bas
aucun poil plus haut le petit ouf allez
j'espère que s'est adjugé bon dieu
alors donc on en était on en est et où
on était là stouff
où elle car elle y eu deux là je suis
dans l'entre-deux je pense brutale
chasse et fatou modo vous à nous
confirmer ça et c'est son cas était joué
de la part d'un quart à l'hyper logique
il délivre son fou qui allie des gones a
extrêmement dangereuse
ok merci pour vos retours du coup je ne
touche plus à rien
cavaliers pro 5 ok donc qu'on balaie pas
en cavale et prend logique au passage
c'est ça qui prenait la casse des cartes
dieu s'ils étaient des lost est
d'essayer d'installer une pièce là
donc il prend ce gros fous j'ai envie
s'est repris
on vient un petit peu solidifier cette
diagonale qui était dangereuse je pense
que l'idée du meba montre a dit elle a
beaucoup de monde at il dit les gars on
achète on va révolutionner plus qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait faire un time's up en
chef time's up
baby mettre des joueurs on doit deviner
quelle joie à sa plaque sur la
tombe également pas facile d'abord
il faut quand même des caractéristiques
y avait dix sept ans que moralement au
times je suis pas je suis pas le
meilleur joueur et mgm dans le
jardin
mais aussi à
ces lignes
vous à l'aise avec son corps qu'avec les
mots stouff
cavaliers 6,5 et la menace et si paul
davois ils veulent élever sa fille kate
ça a été pareil très sereinement parfait
a dit simon les haltes autocontrôle
vis-à-vis magique aussi à rennes bkb cap
et du cou bk donc il a pêché 4 b 4 a
cédé
sans danger parce que c'est comme type 2
et 1 4 et 6 4 les grottes de ryan là
mais je sais pas quel animal là mais
c'est aurait du sens
ici payent que je pense qu'il va pas
être très content si tout le temps
il écoute mais en fait une fois une fois
que tu as créé une fois que tu as mangé
qu'avec pas une position qui est très
très bonne comme la sienne je pense que
le plus faire demi-tour quoi il peut y
aller vraiment franco et à la grand
combe et 14 ainsi découvre son roi ils
croient protégés s'énerve et b4 s'éprend
obligatoire pour en débloquer mais après
manger avec avec le toujours en b3 voilà
et est attaqué c'est 5 et rehausser les
quatre derrière donc bon coup c'est un
bon coup mais quatre je pense très belle
inspiration même pas si facile à voir
d'ailleurs
dans la surprend dès 8 je pense à
premier 3 ouais et surtour ces villes
par exemple le bureau fermé car voilà
quelqu'un derrière d'aucun décès des
recoins suffixe car avec la manière
proactive moulin loin des balles ça donc
attention à ça mais bon l'idée existe
il ya la paire de fou ça expo d'occasion
il est par terre moi j'aime bien les
noirs encore honnêtement et un peu plus
avec les noirs répression mauroy et plus
safe
ça paraît toujours pour même si c'est
une belle robe pour trouver pareil
shipping co ça paraît toujours dangereux
pour les blondes et dans leurs jouets le
roi il est ouvert j'ai pas de caisse qui
défendent le roi les castings
le remarqua mais quand même bien plus en
sécurité
dont il est clair qu'ils s'y
déclarent que 40 mal avantage
je te propose qu'on allait voir de
petits and chic était beau draguant veut
dire voir s'il a réussi à s'en sortir un
petit peu ou pas yes go
et je vais mettre la carte même
champagne jetons attendant puisque c'est
la partie
qui nous intéresse le plus pour rien
rater alors
alors alors retour on en est et où l'on
était ici ils venaient de se prendre au
sérieux donc ceux qui nous rejoignent
but que nous marquons de rien qu'à les
pièces noires dans le challenger qu'à un
demi point sur quatre et qu'affronte la
joueuse russe polina ou alors il fait
toujours beau tournoi et fumé d'aucune
boileau expression d'amour était resté
là avec ses problèmes
sur 4 blanche autour du rock
c'est ça alors ici on avait dit qu'il y
avait un air france les 6 que des
menaces et avec le groupe où alain way
et on n'avait pas entièrement h7 comme
défense c'est ce qu'il aime il a d'abord
un changement des quatre
jeux suivants c'est aussi parce que tu
veux tu pensais que roy h7 direct des
parents en angers7 fr
bon écoute a préféré
cet ordre de coups échangés et tris
prise ouais
encore manger
j'imagine donc je pense que c'est un bon
coup ou encore prend la fuite je crois
qu'ici je pense qu'il y avait une menace
qui était prévu pour les noirs et d'amd
6 pour changer un peu la main
la pression avec un difficile à jouer
donc je pense que si on en arrive à
échanger des pièces il pourrait on peut
s'en sortir will et georges bédard les
soulagerait largement elle doit réussir
ça c'est clair
et on peut retrouver ça va désorganiser
un petit peu les noirs mais d'un bep 6
km 6 voilà et après j'ai la m5 c'est un
e 5 qui est partie stouff logis encore
une fois
bon j qu'on actionne le deuxième levier
centrale pour le blog ça fait mal aux
coups d'objets de manger
cause du cloud âge
madame forme regardez juste chez les
blancs à part la moindre faiblesse
car chez les noirs dont d'avoir
d'un trois cibles surtout deux et ce roi
qui passera quand même disque loi est
faible c'est pas de l'emploi tant des
bibles et même cavalier de cavaliers f4
avec un cavalier en russie ce qu'elle
veut le plus qui peut être affaibli avec
ses trois succès deux
donc on ne sait pas encore comment ça va
se terminer comment ça va se passer mais
pour l'instant c'est clair que le blanc
promet davantage
donc marco c'est quand même pas fait
matin ça aurait pu être pire il prend la
colonne d'eau verte il a encore il
encore des semences position et quel
dessein comme forza pour essayer de
concrétiser je pense davantage
stratégique paraître le gardien
champion vaisselle depuis même si sept
ans qu'il a dû prendre isis bi courant
alors et
surtout reproche tout qu'est ce qui se
passe
je sais pas
qui avait senti honoré le d'amendé
singaye un lien pitois jouve rien quand
on m'a parlé de briques à bouger à cause
de la pluie ou à paris fils adam en
mangeant une tour voire lac huppé real à
damas m et ça c'est sans espoir ce type
de finale évidemment il a soufflé par
contre rien n'a pas pris il a joué pour
17 ans il essaie de combler comme il
peut
et quatre au moi je suis pas super
pas totalement
ce cavalier bout il participe est
parfaite ouais mais le 4
mai regarde ce fou c'est si lui d'après
moi ce que j'aime bien c'est que
regarder deux
derrière ce qu'on disait ici qui avait
sacré faiblesse
après qu'ils aient des 5 donc après cet
échange maintenant on se retrouve avec
quatre faiblesses au lieu de deux en
fait ou c'est vrai surtout aussi autour
des 2 kg était une bonne idée un pour
essayer de se fondre au jeu est activée
et là du coup on a échangé le fou qui a
pas kg 2 donc c'est intéressant nalin
jeudi là on joue encore sur le clonage
donc il ya un quart des
dames font à chaque est une médaille si
si peut-être oui
parce que regarder bien d'un point à 5
le plonger le pas manger parce qu'il
écoute par le fruit 4 il ya vallée prend
d'améliorer tout reprend 1,8 comme tout
à l'heure on avait dit je pense à vous
montrer un ici donc qu'ils perdront
cette idée là c'est vous vraiment à fond
sur sur nos qualités de bricoleur avec
les pièces blanches il ou clouage et du
coup on retrouve dans une finale avec en
plus
un peu plus actifs une tortue j'active
il y
donc dans la partie sur frikat la jouer
d'alger cette barre contraire il
s'enlève un très logiquement de ce
vis-à-vis désagréable et le fou
maintenant a quand même trouvé une
superbe une superbe 15 ans
leproux il est indélogeable où il a pu
prendre tout le monde est bien protégé
et mais d'énormes pressions sur une à
l'endroit des noirs
y'a rien de moins pour le petit français
mais
est très dur à défendre en pratique
c'est la refaire dans cette position en
brèche pour les maladroits
en fait on affronte attaque l'option
vraiment pour toi pour trouver des jeux
ou quoi et toi le fuir subir subir à
voir jusqu'à perdre c'est dur de trouver
des coups mais moi je trouve cette
horreur des 5
aucun contre jeu ça qui est très très
dur
je pense qu'ici il faudrait pouvoir
échanger d'un petit échange les dames
c'est toujours moi bien évidemment mais
t'as résolus quand même beaucoup de tes
problèmes dont je pense que tu entends
si on retient des derniers de
l'échiquier moi c'est clair abbas et
s'agrippe maman le noir y être très bien
ça mais ça m'arrive et
les blancs n'ont aucun intérêt à changer
d'âme ça aiderait pour les noirs dont
closer il ya eu d'un bep huit partants
de 520 est donc d'amener vite
voilà et là il ya eu d'un bep 8 du coup
on attaque le pion
[Musique]
aux essais de s'activer un peu d'abord
on a tous passé un on s'en rendait pas
trop content de ce qu'il était tellement
faites le mais
pourquoi pas par balles le 5 août
le tacticien qui est dans la place sur
dame prend bien terminer ses rideaux
nous avons peut-être un peu par chance
tout pour detroit
je sais pas si ça marche on
reste au final de tabac
car du fait notamment perdu et a perdu
une finale comme ça qu'elle dément
il avait deux tournois oui oui elle doit
être perdante je pose mes boots tu as
beaucoup plus de choses que dans que
dans celle qu'il a joué à lors de la
dernière ronde oui mais non commencés
moi-même l'attaqué l'attaquant fut
membres avaient été malades ou dans
l'autre puis on est bien on n'en est pas
là mais au moins d'essayer de faire
quelque chose quoi
oui oui va revenir passivement
[Musique]
bon
on
va laisser se battre pour essayer de
sauver peut-être un demi point en tout
cas ça serait déjà bien que je pense de
la position voilà je serai une bonne
nouvelle ouais et du coup qu'est ce
qu'on va avoir tout
s'est pas passé grand chose chez carat
scène j'essaie d'une couronne mondiale
et
j'apprends qu'il est très mal à ça cette
mauvaise nouvelle bon
c'est la barre qui sert avec s'est
affolé la barbe ou la barbe blanche j'ai
pas vraiment ouvert le truc imposition
rien impliqué comme beaucoup il a envoyé
g51 fringues
bas il fait les gens un coup en basque
en fait
[Musique]
c'est le positionnement bien de regarder
je sentais des pièces mais
c'est vraiment plus sont révisables
qui a valu cinq années magiques où je
crois qu'à valait 5 analogie on arrive
sur un court succès mène de quatre aces
un joli coin d'un veto de la part de de
la part de richard apporte donc on joue
vraiment sur quasiment à renvoyer que
les noirs foulard aux baraques se fout
je ne le ferais genre est absent nous du
nord en profite les blancs profite c'est
à étapes sur les cases noires rouges et
trois dames b2 et comment
la jouer times est
ok peut-être qu'il a eu tort que jean
cavalier
g6
il y avait foule et si soudée
pas très regardant sur planté en 67 kg
3 ou g4s si les bleus arrivent vraiment
résoudre ce problème de full hd 2 il
voit
même si ce flou il a l'air extrêmement
fort il peut aussi être abordée
le point principal donnant ces femmes
les cases noires qui sont vraiment
affaiblis où il allait aussi un îlot de
3 contre 1 ici plus tard je compte bien
pousser alors je prouverai en bessin ne
sait si les six mois une position même
si la barbe blanche un petit peu affolée
ses derniers coups ça reste très
compliqué il ya vraiment rien de fait
les deux joueurs ou 25 minutes chacun il
reste voit quoi jouer tout peut se
passer je pense encore moins mon nom
vous est intéressant de voir il ya une
option si cette nouvelle tour 1 pour
enlever cette cette tour qui contrôle la
colonne après c'est pas un coup dur
équipes sont plus évidentes à mais ok
vous êtes loin en disant que tu peux pas
ne pas garder le statu quo parce que ta
tour n'a besoin pour des photos de
femmes
ont ici juste ont désiré et on gagnerait
une pièce
ça peut être intéressant finalement ce
qu'on a une tour passive outre une tour
dont les cellules ouvertes de la
position des échanges et ça peut être
intéressant pour les blancs mais tu vas
tu auras le rend bien que plus grand
chose on est fermée avec le plombier
trois ans la tour 1 pour condamner en v
et après un petit problème
et c'est limite à gagner ce pas xo
bienvenue à toi
[Musique]
concrètement pour saluer l'arrivée de
sagan est un petit
joueur préféré japon mais la nuit
fabiano caruana la position était chaud
donc plus puisqu'elle a évolué un petit
peu
bougé par des rapides on peut donc là on
abat ce qu'on avait dit il ya eu les
quatre de jouer tout en traçant dans
l'honneur et maintenant on apprend b3
ouais attaques ont été leurs yeux fermés
bécade ont juste pour revenir très vite
qu'ils étaient assez spectaculaire quand
même comme coup
ils ont pas sans les charges détour
d'une famille 40 des
lilas et maintenant on va jouer alors
bekaert non parce qu'on avait dit
qu'avec avaler ces quatre avec un
problème de porsche par rapport à et
aussi du fou aux trois ans prise ça peut
compliquer et donc on traite ici à la
place des jambes et quatre pages qui
dansait vite et surtout on sait comment
je peux défendre et son adversaire avant
tout c'est un retour à activer donc tour
serra tu proposes pour attaquer les
pions qui a l'air assez logique
et comment je répondrais cavalli 17ème à
l'armement nous balader cette part vers
le faire c'est pas drôle esprit de
retirer ce qu'avait dit subir à ces voix
là mais il faut défendre son mandat
voilà le laisser me trouver autre chose
à faire
simplement j'ai eu 4 mais j'aime
parapublic ou
le cas mais les castelroussins ya pas de
candidats jurés moment là ah oui le
canal défense ou proches de l'ue
marchent pas du tout autant pour moi
si c'est très mauvais à flot oui oui
c'est 4 sa dépendance ça dépend pour qui
passaient
très beau pour sip khobar contre
et qu'elle va l'aider c'est un peu ça un
peu simple pas beau ça te faire clouer
n'en ont vraiment joué allant du
parlement quoi manger à mes cahiers des
sept familles c'est pas un petit joueur
mais il faut trouver une idée là c'est
pas évident faites moi il n'a pas le
torse c'est bien encore cipango donc été
réfléchi aussi à peut-être pour des
reins pour un chant dans une moindre
mesure
pour des retours ça c'était de couler
les plus logiques priori que cette
tourelle fait rien c'est la pièce créée
en vue d'améliorer ici et sont les deux
colosses alors qu'elle aura un rôle
actif pour salariale plus logique un
bain c'est plus direct insultes montage
des quatre indices là c'est quand même
il me semble pour jouer bref le tour
c'est un mois et donc si ce carnet il
décide de rendre son pion de plus tivo
kg pas m'accrocher je vais être c'est de
trouver une idée qu'est ce qui pourrait
bien faire
chaque île wang qishan ligne
d'ordinateurs carrière
d'ordinateurs justement les dames à sac
ça pourquoi pas au sérieux du vis-à-vis
évident et ce quand même pas facile à à
avoir surtout qu'on sait c'est que même
si peut-être que 40 hommes peut la voir
dans son rêve ses cavaliers ces quatre
coins spectaculaire waouh
donc l'idée c'est de bloquer cette
protection des pièces lourdes des blancs
dans la colonne c'est sur le fou pour
donc attaquer le faut on met quand même
deux pièces en trésors première chose si
recettes qui peut sembler résoudre un
problème en encaissant au passage du
matériel lie à la petite tactique
préférée dessous une petite une petite
découverte pour gagner la dame up donc à
râler à 3 sur les aussi possible de
penser qu'elle a trois coups aussi
possible effectivement le cavalier mais
d'un coup je m'en tiendrais la partie
de quoi
la différence ici c'est que tu as donné
une pièce par rapport à la partie de la
tour où cavaliers coûte la dame
à audenge pour winamp ou bien tu donnes
tout cavalier en fait
exactement deux tu fais la même chose
sans le perdre sur une plage bleue pièce
ok donc juste ici pour contrer comprend
7 est pas possible donc sur des
pancartes et bien on fait tout repenser
5 qu'on récupère notre pièce avec les
noirs et retire un bateau pour moi il
est bon pour un petit
sou dans un camp naturiste là il a plus
rien devant lui salvat c'est complexe on
pense échapper
ici c'est probablement gagnon pour les
noirs pensent
à leur contrôle en raison d'un massacre
et fort qu
est ce qu aurait ici une
défense
mais elles sont des lignes difficile à
trouver quand même pour les joueurs
mais je pense que c'est totalement
c'est trop bas tour s'arrête et jouait
donc voilà caruana on va voir si
pour l'instant depuis début juin il
n'est pas en grande forme où il a fait
que des nuls il a peiné à obtenir des
avantages à presser car là il sera
neutralisé plus tôt mais il permet aussi
mais ils ont carrément il manque d'éclat
de plus de tournois il est solide mais
yann par le petit truc en plus je peux
lui faire regagner les victoires comme à
la belle époque typiquement bien baliser
les gagner ouais ça se fait
ce sera très fort coup alors attention
explique autre époque géant bleu pur on
mange pas pourrait faire 6 4 mais voilà
rsa risque d'aller traire le coude à
flot surtout les plombs
ok bah parti à tavannes olivier suivre
l'idée de cave et laissé 4
[Musique]
et avec l'aval en dépit de nos marques
il peut aussi peut-être trouvé par
élimination parce qu'on est dans une
position bas comme on l'a vu ensemble
n'y a pas moyen de défendre ce plan
il n'y a pas tant de coups candidats
cavale il a pas de case n'y a pas trop
de cours est bizarrement les pièces sont
assez bien placé
c'est dur de trouver des coups avec les
bras donc peut-être que ces idées de dab
ou hébergés dans le cerveau du
champion américain
alors où va peut-être le lait c'est
justement trouvé ce crew ou pas est allé
voir un autre échiquier
qui mangent regarder la partie de la
partie de myeurop pressante ah oui tu as
raison ça fait longtemps qu'on n'est pas
les voir alors là j'ai assez surpris ya
pas eu les deux fous
ouais financièrement j'ai rapidement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya vu une
grosse séquence tactique on a vu tout ça
ressemble tout à l'heure initié par vent
fort est
à priori c'était tout retourné contre
lui donc on était resté là et là il n'a
pas joué dans un programme qui avait
l'air
assez logique mais oui à [ __ ] on
insiste n'aurais pas pensé
ou
garde sont fous ils mangent un pion
important
ils se retrouvent autour contrefout
cavaliers deux pions
cavaliers des six pour prendre les cases
dame f3
c'est ça qui a été jouée par
la liga derrière ton temps rennes pour
menacer d un
des trucs sur un peu partout mais où
quelques c5
assez logique hausse il n'y a ni mois
d'été récupération pure au
hockey et oui c'est edouard qui joue
pour le gars ici un bon apparemment
battre en ciel noir qui joue pour le
gain de points montre donc on a cinq
contres face à
l'envoyé h4
évidemment un piège dans lequel elle
même sa garde et star ne tomberait pas
assez d'armes dans ces trois
paires la dame qui
ressort tactique est très classique ici
donc h4h qui veut empêcher l'élection de
miss mayotte en cours en amphi pense pas
que mauvaises langues à un duel à la
rigueur quoi je dois faire un petit cran
possible
ok on veut tranquillement m leroy l'abri
ou n'avoue cadre blanc je veux qu'on
peut se faire dès 3h cases blanches
cavaliers qui vient se recycler je pense
pour se mettre aux rêves si celui ci
sera bientôt même si ces cavaliers
il défend il attaque
ces quatre
là je pense qu'ici avec les blancs
vont ils jouent pour l'annuler s'il veut
sauver lé demi point et pour ça il a
intérêt à essayer de simplifier donc si
ses deux pions la disparaissent de
l'échiquier balle matériel sera kahn
beaucoup plus réduit ça laissera moins
de possibilités et c'est ce qui s'est
passé aux prises à la fois chez
vous n'avez pas vu la queue d'un poste
mais ok reprend reprend 1,7 à
d'improbables je tenais cavalli aussi
et c'est assez joli joli ouais moi celle
là il ya quand même une pression encore
le cas je sais car c'est un très bon un
très joli coup ici pour
pour simplifier la position je belles
belles trouvailles alain forest mais bon
travail ce qui est très tactique un qui
sait pas comment nous commandions soyez
partie des rois et fuite
ou g6
qu'alexis on parle et les fous de cases
blanches 10 passes de l'échiquier est
bon il faudrait maintenant il va
s'atteler à essayer de récupérer ce pion
c4 alors ton série qui est apparemment
c'est blender devant la barre noire qui
a sauté par dessus le filet
partout on était comme ça l'a fait pour
serres a vraiment été jouées ou page et
de regarder sur la caméra
cet ajout retour c'est un
cancer le problème c'est quoi c'est que
tu t'éloignes de la défense du pion f2
il va se faire très sûr et j'ai ensuite
pas trop faire cavaler j'ai quatre
points en
[Musique]
jeu c'est comme ça juste pour
apparemment fallait faire échec
mais essayez de faire des échecs sur
cases blanches
des choses comme ça
trouver une sorte de perpétuer alors
pourquoi il n'a pas trouvé ça il a dû
penser que le roi noir vices cachés
j'imagine plutôt roger 6 il ya d'ambea
c'est marrant cette géométrie de gaz
blanc tu là où elle arrive à faire des
échecs de partout cette dame
est à priori le roy n'avaient pas
vraiment
s'échapper facilement de toucher échec
au mans sur va perdre ce pion
et du prêt les problèmes vraiment nous
des concerts et donc tour si j'entends
beaucoup de mes 4 donc des quatre
combats justes on défend le pion ça
empêche d'en bessette
au calme et ombragé 2 puisque jusqu où
l'on veut défendre ce pion à terme aussi
que moi c'est peut-être se faire
attaquer
et donc sur un des boutons ces deux il y
aura toujours les chèques donc roger des
coûts inutiles
ou alors est ce qu'on peut voir
peut-être d'abord stouff zerka 2003
france sanef pas effectivement il ya
juste cette prendre le dessus et je vais
te couper ça me fout en quelques
secondes ce qui est coûteux pas de
problème le premier rien tu te laisses
recharger son téléphone on va perdre
juste la caméra pour notre faute si
c'est pas grave vous êtes habitués
maintenant est en fait le gros point de
toute cette variante devant le forez
pour louer son cou ses quatre
ici pour simplifier la position il a
fait cette petite goutte tactique le
problème c'est que il n'a pas récupéré
ces quatre
ce qui était indispensable pour
égaliser la position est maintenant bas
la juste deux pièces en fait
pour pour la tour est plus teinte on
passait à bord le roi noir à trouver
facilement un abri est en fait les noirs
juste l'escort espions et ça va être
complètement complètement gagnant pour
mamediarov ont fait
croire qu est ce qu ils vivent à courir
là bas il ya encore des idées là il va
tenter dé perpète
il va falloir être prêt cyr pour le
joueur azéri et d'ailleurs alors s'il
gagne pour être retrouvé en tête
on ira jouer des parties pas forcément
autre époque et des la réussite qui
penche de son côté en restant dans ce
tournoi m'a appris la latitude 1 et il
était vraiment dur pour gagner le club
voilà aujourd'hui fait une bonne partie
est d'ailleurs je pense c'est le premier
jour on est à trois heures de jeu aucune
partie déterminée
ça joue surtout les échiquiers même
vous dire même guilde est
celui qu'on n'est pas allé voir beaucoup
donc aujourd'hui c'est duda
célia bouchard stouff alors que pourtant
ils allient position perdre que la fiche
si mérite qu'on s'y attarde
on
n'attend qu'à peine plus point noir un
bon boulot refuge quand même trois
pièces manquantes ont patiemment ses
pertes recommencer en a cinq
les blancs tango basse et au chant au 6
mai le pion est bloqué
c'est tellement vite
ah oui c'était cette femme dont les
avait laissés parce qu'ils avaient joué
très lentement le début et elle veut
passer à la vitesse supérieure ils ont
eu beaucoup de coups reçus et donc voit
pas l'avenir surtout les quoi ça prend
beaucoup trop
trois valises et on va essayer de voir
ensemble
alors juste jadis qui vend les dames ses
trois langues de chat entame ses trois
huttes et actif de croix
elle partiez l'album bonne pour être
retourner vite fait
à quels moments ici
oui mais le concerto mlh arrache la de
paris où il faut être payé à la
fourchette
pjanic est
donc malheureusement tactiquement ça
marche 3,23 c'est une bonne idée mais
nous
[Musique]
alors d'actes ou des motos
nos moutons polonais polono-russes du
dadou dakar yakine
juste pour rappel lire dans cette
ouverture les bleus ont sacrifié un pion
mais ils ont dû contre eux et notamment
sur le petit rock qui va arriver plus
tard il y aura il y aura de la tacc
crise près donc à cannes 2 tous passés
chez les noirs ici
comme ces deux tyrans accès la partie
haute et on a mangé ses foucades et
quand même vraiment puissant mais le
cavaliere a aussi un sacré travail à y
prend du tout alors intéressant
ils pointent du piaui bêtement et c'est
moi qui parle profite juste pour
protéger et asseoir son passé ses quatre
spécialistes des tactiques en dehors des
compactes tactiquement 300 vins
complexes mais
deux styles machine en deux jambons il
envoie il envoie d'oudaï prend des
risques
il progresse que stratégiquement nous
pouvons pas ses protégés à l'école m
formé il ya du jeu sur le roi
ankara qui ne les revoyait son toulon f5
ça commence à la tour va sûrement
revenir via f1
et f6 qu'une réaction m'a eu peur du
scandale si c'est de faire
ce père battait à terme je pense sur les
cases lui même
aussi sa logique et j'essaie
aussi de casser ils vous solide et je
pense qu'il ya pas une partie où les
blondes ou pas c'est qu'à tout genre dit
donc le g4 qui parlent
crient au feu rouge et 4 des particules
c'est incroyable saga nice-matin réseau
savent déjà qui prend le plus de risques
clairement doudard rapport aussi un peu
dans le même style j'ai l'impression
depuis le début du tournoi
la du box tu prends pas mal de risques
mais des fois il faut citer petit nul
solide
mais benzema font aussi
rouler droit qui s'enlève de cette
colonne j'ai du coût équivalent qui va
s'ouvrir devant leurs yeux effrayés
bon j'ai vu tour à fond et pas toujours
du coup intéressant
pourquoi il va plutôt et first of
steel a pas peur de la bollinger
way n'est peut-être plus intéressés par
la colonne je sais pas
tu peux aussi aller il faut aussi aller
sur sur 3 via via geffroy aussi
[Musique]
tu veux pas que les trois échanges en
fait il veut garder les tortures ne
gardait son il se dit ok lui apprendre
probablement de première place
et donc chacun sa colonne fin prêts ont
généralement un nip n'auront qu'à se
branchent généralement le blanc d'oeuf
de tueur cases blanches sur la planche
opposer une fois de verse donc sur le
fou qui manque au noir on pourra juste 5
cet accueil je crois pas qu'on
puisse lui était très chaude ici on a
vraiment on pouvait avoir que des
parties décisives dans l'absolu il ya
peu de chance mais bon c'est peu c'est
bien celle là guerre surtout les
échiquiers la journée de repos je prends
ça fait du bien aux joueurs sont venus
avec des intentions extrêmement
offensive
et après de la liste jadis saddam
il est vrai qu'un peu car hacking c'est
quand même le maire de france a
actuellement dans le monde dont on voit
qu'il a quand même bien fait aussi dans
ceux
là quand on voit aussi qu'il prend aucun
risque aucune de ce parti qui fait des
nuls rapide
du doigt les blancs il a clairement le
temps que ça change quoi mais après ils
attaquent mais ce qu'elle me faisait
quoi pendant côté all in non plus quoi
des risques mais oui il a un écran des
risques mais c'est pas non plus aux
lignes quoi et du coup bon c'est bien
ils forcent carrière qui n'a joué une
partie et il força à une partie a joint
un truc et puis et puis là les blancs
quoi un talent et blanc et ben
si nous davayé nord d'être que la nuit
il redit bon ok pourquoi pas oui c'est
nier la lah avec avec les avec les
blancs on a vraiment envie de tenter
l'avantagent dû créer
l'écart yaqing qu'envoie sanction c'est
pendant ce temps on se trouve ah bon je
dis car yakine qui envoie son pion c'est
pendant ce temps il a joué c3 c3
qu'est-ce qui me faire me bats pour ce
faire ces deux bons gènes à tour
bien vu ce qu'on a vu
[Musique]
cette dame et ses 95 blanche aussi mais
le pion ses hippo être faible un joueur
que 10 aghanistan je suis assez d'accord
avec lui c'est vrai que c'est une grosse
prise de risque autant la tepa ses
protégés aldi dect avance ça y est à
plus de soutien à
tomber car au pire qui va tenir des
rendre fou donc que c'est vrai ça va
l'option il n'est pas comment faibles
mais sur des cartes ça quand même le
foot le décodage de sable ocre et lombez
pas forcément l'idéal non plus dans le
roi dans un supermarché
pas fans sont couchés 3 mais ok bah il
veut il veut peut-être penser des
changes de tours je sais pas la position
encore une fois tu es très chaude il a
plus que 5 minutes dauda par contre ça
c'est une info importante
cinq minutes on entend quelques couleurs
0 28e co
12 ou pour arriver au 40e et à avoir 50
plus de rage ou vu la position ça peut
être un problème
on va pas la cadence
1h40 pour 40 ou au 40e coup vous avez 50
minutes dur à jour automatique
donc 50 coupe pour 20 coups et aux du
coup au 60e coup on aura encore 15
minutes jusqu'à la fin la partie
avec toujours qu'avec tour 36 le
parcours des sens si on en arrive là
c'est pas ces patients ont vu qu'on a
quand même que tu es parti de combat
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible qu'on en
ait une qui se prolongea ça peut durer
longtemps
effectivement ça fait longtemps qu'on
appelle le 15 scènes non parce que alors
est-ce qu'on partirait pas rare de
cancer et à raison marteleur tuer la
voix de la raison on va faire une petite
pub il reviendra donc avec l'évolution
la partie du champion du monde va voir
s'il va les chercher le point et les
pièces noires marche à tout de suite a
tout de suite
[Musique]
donc
et
[Musique]
le
oh
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour au ch retrouve
avec grand tennis car ce n
est guère à cet échelon c'est quoi le
coup à maroilles g8
de
hockey pourquoi incollables par la
seconde rangée est libérée ce fou
ou à 6
avec son fourgon il tapait sur sur un
burin
et là il est peut-être me lasser des
détroits il contrôle et contrôle des
cases par rapport à la pression sur ce
pion tu peux être intéressant ni goût
est ici
intéressant aussi le fameux être quatre
cantons par les grandes hélices est
décidé à jouer maintenant donc que le
fou un exercice un peu de pression sur
un quartier dit ok c'est le moment où il
ya les gens voyagent 4
aux mal logés bien avec les bleus on n'a
pas envie de me casser notre structure
salle et d'y perdre est complètement les
pièces les pièces blanches avec les
noirs pardon n'a pas envie de casser
sur eve catraz du coup il va jouer pour
baie vitrée qui là aussi au passage
bonjour voici se libérer la colonne b
dont la tour
de défense loyales queiroz ont pas dû
payer si j'étais le collectées pendant
trois jours tu te méprends du concours
et
les pousse sur longue on sait mais
malheureusement c'est pas nous qui
décidons de la durée d'accord chess
comme twitch ces six minutes par heure
donc c'est sûr que c'est long ça on est
bien d'accord avec vous
to rob élite impact la dame ça commence
à sortir un petit peu russie moi je
trouve pour les blancs il ya danger est
réel mais qu'une seule caste pour la
balle océans à cap bref
pour rester à la maison il faut oui
sinon il y avait tant fait froid on a
ici magnus bon maçon fut attaquée il
gagne un temps sur la dame
joue au hockey je reviens
tu allais dire un truc mon nom ok
alors là autant te dire que grandiose
c'est son rêve de répéter les coups je
pose qui lui arrache la main si bagley
se répète pour le vernis
sur l' attaque j'ai dit ok c'est bon
c'est prix d'accord
donc le casting
comment éviter la répétition avec avec
les noirs puisque je pense que c'est
qu'un scène qui veulent jouer pour le
gars ici non
ou pas qui se sont passés dans cette
position il un jour moi il est cloué
j'en sais rien je pas dans sa tête
non je pense qu'il va y venir
je pense que si il a pris pour arriver
jusque là ça serait très surprenant mais
accepte être qu' il peut avoir un
ressenti différent
à noter que les deux joueurs
respectivement 12 et 16 minutes
6 pour le manger de 4 à y renoncer car
pourquoi
les
agréments le chauffard président et
qu'il a répété m 5
donc la grande étape des 4 qui part
et maintenant peut-être une idée assez
fou de
dakhla dame
si la dame à la pac en sikassois le
retournera 4 soit que sacrifier sur
d'abba quatre femmes
au parc on se fout
on m'accuse pas toi tu vas pas nous
faire une heure de répétition de l'autre
comme ça par contre ce serait ce serait
très surprenant à l'espace go / 3d
faisant mon
tour avec par attention à la colonne
d'air
si la colonne elle vient à s'ouvrir ça
va être dramatique
c'est pas si facile
je
trouve étrange trois banques de chine
c'est une très belle job est rien pour
le coup après il en est capable avec
l'idée de corruption mange le faut
évidemment la bouche p3c permis n'est
d'accord de récupérer 100 mo il vous
faut du
courage je prends la fois un gîte urbain
et prend un coup de matraque d'un petit
c'est vraiment mon vieux mourront il
faut on revient en arrière
dee
da 24 forcé la dame a pas d'eau de gaz
et donc pour
h3b attention parce que là pourquoi pas
37.7 et pourquoi je ne gagne pas juste
une pièce tout ce qu'il ya une très
jolie infiltration ici
on est une pièce de moins pour l'instant
on
va voir
donc le coustous fin tu vas trouver un
mât de ces termes à 2 évidemment ils ont
consacré sous pli et là c'est la nuit la
plus de cases
et à regarder imaginons qu'on avance sur
le pion pour essayer de défendre aurait
juste la présentation ici et c'est tout
à fait un travail magnifique et là c'est
c'est la fin pour le roi
ramener le roi blanc
fois qu'elle tue et
est compliquée cette variante ans et
c'est pas sûr que quelqu'un cette voie
ça il peut avoir peur
s'il ya une autre avec le fou là pour le
pour le gall
servian
17h15 c'est qu'un chien on voit pas
jouer deux finales en
nocturne - non non il ya bientôt deux
mois et la part du lion
on doit tenir je crois que la finale
soyez x 6
et il accepte la de la pétition soit il
y rentre dans cette variante il a plus
qu'une minute
j'ai regardé un peu son petit language
air un peu
à peu place des grandes et lucie fait
genre
je réfléchis mais en fait non j'attends
du cheval c'est sûr que l'on dit aussi
il croise même le doigt de pied
je te prie je vous aussi on a tous déjà
été dans cette situation on la croirait
adversaire répète
je m'y attendais
vous c'est pas ce qu'il va faire
fou n'est pas fou odeurs et c'est
drôlement intéressante
d'amal 4
500 km et ça va être intéressant de
jouer avec tours fion contre dame sait
même pas si clair mais bon passons
ouais quand même je suis posé on verra
si ça arrive pas on va supposer des
vingt quatre
toi je crois est ce qu'il ya un autre
policier jour il
ya pas trop de ses quatre précédentes
ses quatre sacres ont réduit la colonne
qui s'ouvre vraiment je trouve que c'est
vraiment fou deux tours h3
et il doit il doit elle
s'apprête à
valoir
et ça c'est pas si facile à évaluer
non mais là plus de temps de
7 minutes
pour jouer commun de toulon 22-12
c'est hyper chaud ici assez facile et
oui vous tour attend on n'a pas vu 72
coups mais c'est peut-être là bien vite
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que le composent
et je pense jadis je veux il a joué la
même idée dans l'autre sens
un
scélérat
lui faut remettre dans ses mines au
secours de lui quoi il menace fouet deux
ils menacent peut-être pas que faute
même si me lasse pas des fois des
peut-être pas
effectivement effectivement c'est la bd
mais dans l'autre sens et c'est
peut-être plus bas rhin de lasbordes
si je mange m eps est maintenant
du monde burj damas jack apprend jeunes
entre 1,4 et fouet perdu donc où jolie
petite pointe à près partout donc on est
obligé de prendre du roi et du coup
peut-être nous plonge de 5 à 10 ans
mais là plus qu'il ya plein de monde fou
aux deux parce que mon four b3 il plan
crise comment l'aider ouais ils puissent
là la différence principale c'est que ce
fou là il est vraiment extrêmement
mauvais
alors que plus il a quand même des
perspectives intéressantes
mais la force de leur assignation
vainqueur l'allemand chacun je suis sa
couleur l'aller les noirs jour sans
qu'un planches et et les blancs
proclamant avec d'autres ou b2c cazelles
fou
et georges tournay f2 échec je vais
rejouer en fait les repérages des
victimes à chaque pas grande chose à
faire parce qu'on est que le la tourache
3 d'être en b3 le bac de français cap et
j'arrive pas à venir se case blanche
avec madame ont tous rêvent de roger lui
qui avait pas bon train et on voit que
malgré moi les noix en fait c'est assez
sympa y sont absolument à cette position
s'ils sont beaucoup plus actifs quoi
les pions blancs ils sont tous isolés
quoi y'a aucun kembo
donc mon entourage 3 très bien joué qu'à
sanaa il a fait une fausse joie gros
telle est sa vérité des coûts texte
paris et berlin ou encore devoir
réfléchir pas de nom
et puis un sacré casse tête en
perspective il ya quand même des menaces
des thèmes des fois j'ai découvert c'est
ça paraît comme dangereux pour blanc
il a joué il a créé 58
hockey ou deux
fous deux peut-être hf 3,7
et non la différence est classée au
cours d'un premier set à cause de la
peau mais au delà
il a su perdre et juste
en face pointe fruits de ces travaux là
donc il a repris sa
place et la rue adoue went away s'avère
logique
et peut-être qu'il faut attendre l'e3
que je tente sur le budget
et sur d'apprendre et de froid
oblige
c'est compliqué on sacrifie la qualité
mais
on va chasser la dame de la colonne
baies et d'herbes jeune dame qui va
arriver je vois pas comment tu défends
ici avec les
mêmes c3 sera pas un coin tak tak obama
tout d'un coup
d'investissements chez quatre manches b2
viceira cheikh toronto
mais ces aspects malgré la qualité de
plus à l'air hyper bouche voilà souvient
mme au pouvoir dans cette cause
cette fois c'est le moment d'activer le
cavaliere d'aller manger inscrire
ici même tout comme fou aussi c'est
compliqué déjà pour le pour les blancs
parce que celui des purs ouais en fait
tu as vendu à un truc à prendre les
décisions pour le blond beau ce que tu
as beaucoup de problèmes je m dames bc
hatten un malin avec ta clope sur quatre
attaques le pilote le coupé deux ans sur
la tactique
et
je sais comment on fait quand je prends
une dernière fois
c'est peut-être le trou et du griffoul à
tout rachat soient défendus au pour papa
prenant finalement
n'a toujours pas de résultat après 3h30
de jour là déjà il donne surtout les
échiquiers x profil
du coup ce serait très beau ainsi qu'à
celle du sexe de qualité
franchement ça pourrait être très mal
parti
à voir bonbons pendant combat on a eu
deux parties nulles
[Musique]
double
champion on voyait venir en soit voilà
comment bien galvaudé ce qui est bizarre
c'est
peut-être qu'avec la maîtrise du coup on
voit encore des titres en train de
réfléchir au lycée je pense pas que
cette analyse
les prises
du coup bon les deux amériques chez les
jésuites qui est qu'elle est blanche
devait donc la pression mais vite et en
forme leader du tournoi
la suède solide et on avait vu que nos
vertus rétais pas flamboyant
non large pour tous avantages acquis il
ya des époques
les blondes gagnent pas mieux et le ciel
une petite taille qui continue
son bonhomme de chemin
la membre il avait il eu fini minuscule
avec les noirs contre le groupe guéri
c'est cyprien
n'a pas beaucoup vu seydou badjan glande
ouais
je vais me remettre la can cocan scène
pour rien ça vite fait pour voir si on
peut jouer
du box claude
marti
j'aurais pu faire nul ici en fait en
quatorze coups ils allongent les femmes
plus les oiseaux répéter finalement il
n'a pas voulu faire un nul à bois va
c'est tout à son honneur
ça suffit
une récession
passée rien
easy si fourchette
et c'est la dame peut-être qui a des
problèmes pour ressortir à
des ressorts difficile
quoi ça veut dire d'être partie assez
spectaculaire
mange mes 2 pour
reprendre devant son de cavale et a3 qui
lui sera pris au prochain coup iec
noir mais il va avoir assisté aux
activités qui va commencer le pont qui
va d'un moment pas résisté un
jeu
[Musique]
dans la peau du dos qui l'ont fait nul
ici mais nul logique parce que les
blancs aura pour but ne peut pas du tout
progressé complètement bloquée
que verser 4 il est très à plat ces voix
là et j'avais bien j'ai quand même
failli ravir à zarkava lieu qu'à value8
kamal et 10,6
et
10,8 je crois que cet achat est logique
que ce trophée
et
de
tableau se trahissent bon pourquoi pas
bon cru
donc de deux premiers résultats avant de
revenir à ma gauche propose qu'on vous
jette embouteillages ou dakar yakine
puisque c'était très chaud aussi
c'est très très chaud avec le pion c'est
qu'ils étaient envoyés par dans le
joueur russe écart et duda luc hees et
de battes et clairement
placer la caméra qui nous manque je
crois je vais mettre plutôt qu'un seul
alors on en était resté à fois çi ce qui
valut d'être jouée par duda when she
said est selon vous c'est de prouver la
caisse david j'imagine oui sida les
vacances pour et fils ouais
il ya une tour pro tour
dans les logiques et dames c'est casse
un groupe avait d'ailleurs
envisagé pour en activer la dern mettre
la pression sur les cases plonge vers le
roi et une défense sans dommage car ça
pourrait peut-être fou aux
missions qui compliquent la vie à mon
avis un tel symbole juste sa voix il
remplira m'apprend dame monsieur robin
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que je
propose la crtv semaine terrible
st-gall il faut 5 qui est le plus
pressant sur la table y arriver on
trouve 5 on va s'incrire pas due surtout
à jeun 2d prendre cinq dames pendables
pour vouloir défendre l'option de 5 et
aussi venir avec une deuxième fois le 4
pour prendre mon jeu et
j'ai coupé hier put rien sur le roi en
fait est là c'est depuis longtemps après
ça va aller à tarbes ces scènes sont
rois qui va se retrouver faible c'est
saba donc du coup le match 4 serait sur
une route cela s'avère dangereux pour
les blancs
mais c'est faux vous y sont bien joli
mais
c'est un peu artificielle aussi parfois
ou deux belles est revenue juste un mot
d'ordre a pris conscience tama 2 qu'elle
est un peu intéressant
pour scénaristes on va bien contrôler
espions et cavaliers ses 6,7 et je vais
pas
par cardiaque
sachez que sur tours france est un son
idée est celle de lune rouge et l'inde
ont aidé jouer sur le courage
d'en prendre et le cas tu réponds à leur
aide à mardi ouah
non il reporte
damas il réfléchit tentons faut 5 encore
une ressource ici dans cette position
ouais
je crois qu'à des gros problèmes aussi à
cause de de la tour qui regroupe
trop de problèmes ici ok il est
intéressant de
le canaliser 6 et donc il a joué touché
un bouddha ils auraient tous les peuples
de son roi
ouais et après pour projet un d'un pont
j'ai un jeu peut aussi proposer des maps
en g7 à rome a carrément derrière ses
verres bien la raison certainement pour
laquelle
notre famille car il s'agit d'un pas
bouger parce que la dame g7 ça parait
dur apparaît c'est imparable
sur
surtout rejette une proposition nul du
cool entre les deux hommes canal y ait
eu cette idée en vue du
tour c'est en leur tour
dont quoi peut-être étatiste répétition
assez atypique science et petite
répétition de coûts ou un outil bras
est ce que dans les deux langues en
danger depuis peu vous pouvez le dire
bourget chapelon pire il a essayé mais
n'y voit que c'est quand même aussi
c'est pas loin de se retourner contre
lui
cariat qui cale et noir et ceint pas
content de faire un nul on va voir si un
des deux joueurs qui trouvent une idée
pour continuer la partie
mais je pense pas que ça va jouer
parce que au fond de lui karim ben salah
dessus ans
mais il est probable qu'un nul tout le
temps est doux djaballah ils voient que
voit bien que là vraiment pas le choix
et que c'est un peu trop et que le prix
trophée rolim quoi alors voyons voir ton
petit prague les familles a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup évolué et c'est le
lucas leiva lieu le tout dans le tchat
ouais bienvenue à toi dans une finale
on en est et où ont été admis cet et
doctorat pour proposer justement
pranger à 7 tours inactifs on se tourne
vers du jeu ont été changées
on voit que 18ème bourde a l'impression
qu'elle crée noir s'ils font bien parce
qu'il ya deux options ou pas
et pourtant tous non je te manger aux 5
et fabrique à toulouse est donc
exactement et d'ailleurs mon petit
structurelle des creux c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé
châteauroux 5 est mal placé maintenant
par rapport aux pions elle a pu rentrer
sur les colonnes voir à -3 8 ans elle
rompt
et donc n'importe qui a suivi ton plan
je fais le fou il doit rester à la
défense de ce
projet de enfin au 26e coup il arrive
à sortir sa pièce du cachot la tour qui
revient
qu'à bâle etb 1 il veut être le croit en
des bleus je pense moi c'est ça c'est ça
va il veut pas les rockets qu'ils y sont
allés un peu par la barre en finale il
va regrouper ses forces
perception mais surtout réduite je
commente pas ce que
c'est aurais-je confondent la casse et
du coup deux
contrôles et de casques les
est bien là bas je t'ai
bingé roi de deux et maintenant iphone
pour le foot
et pas deux ans on imagine juste
maintenant attention là ces trois points
sont d'excusés
cet îlot de 3 contre 1
ils étaient six
donc dans la partie qu'il y ait des 7
3 t2 et un déstabilisé quand même
rapport il ya un tour de plus
il a même carrément
il met l'euro en b2b l'andeva les
détails horribles pour ces deux là voilà
pourquoi il a celle de g pas l'arrêt
le retour des hommes
ipod forcer les choses et après ouais
c'est pas mal c'est pas con et après mon
gestion cela sera très compliqué de la
mildt lui est loin des 4 manches
d'options quatre morts deux tours être
autrement je
trouve qu'ils ont à prendre celle qui
pourra pas tout manger parce que
non parce que je veux ouais mais s'il
est noir mais tu vois mon cavalier en
existe juste pour illustrer un
mois d'écart droit trop juste 5 j'avais
juste pour montrer ici on peut manger
les pions pour manger mais ensuite parce
que l échange et toutes les pièces
disparaissent et là plus personne pour
arrêter
le pion des comme dame du coup du coup
c'est la loire gagnerait
pas que c'est pas si simple
l'actualité la
tac tac il ya des espions et surtour de
2 5 il a joué et a voulu garder les
tours f6 qui est
numéro colère la barbe blanche comme
vous pouvez le voir des violations donc
être que le minutes et d'avants très
longue date convient de vous montrer
valley si c'est vrai que moi je
comprends ça n'avait pas l'air
on se dit qu'on va perdre ses tgv
moi je pense qu'il s'est dit que c'était
une mort lente alors il a essayé de
garder les pièces et de tenter un peu
les choses là vous voyez sur voilà qui
est tellement actif
voici c'est cet effort champions mais il
va ya marqué c'est terminé non
ouais les deux pions risque de tomber
je pense que rapport devrait aussi
remporter une troisième victoire
s'ils sont précis coup dur pour ton
poulain stouff
way qui l'a peut-être grether ne pas
avoir joué cinq en début de partie si tu
te souviens il a une position
prometteuse le 4-2-4 c'était une carte
pardon et ça sortira royal fuite de
l'espace
l'astuce alors
mais pas les voir depuis longtemps aussi
malaisien qui était complètement gagnant
et c'est pile après le gall devant de
forest ya entre tous alors est ce que
est ce que je vais dire va être le
premier joueur à gagner aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression qu'il verrait bien
partir habiter au retour c'est donc pour
ça
donc c'est un après les dames c'est
cette malin aussi à voir que surtout
repenser quatre daïras
y'aura petite découverte avec france fef
d'eau et en prend ses 4 donc l'idée
étant directement son option et mais
aussi une pression sur ce pion c'est la
dame venait à partir pourrait jouer sur
le courage
de son avocat hier bien il est au
soutien sont purement c'est
indirectement
les rouages des 2% levée de toutes ces
problèmes et donc le foie a laissé la
voie pour que la dame des ponts de
pioncer est ici bas c'est juste comme on
disait tout à l'heure c'est fou cavalier
seul pion contre cette pouf tour
c'est clairement insuffisant pour
reprendre une forest on va voir la suite
br munadi la défaite est proche les
avancées sont qui ont cessé complètement
gagnant si juste d'éviter l'échec
perpétuelle guerre
c'est pas très dur de cacher le roi
tu as reprise
f3 par un échec la dame qui rentrent en
bêta donc
bien joué donc là et joueurs continuent
même où ce taux qui va revenir dans
quelques secondes le temps de payer ce
parc fait partie
internet et les caméras c'est aux
bretons avec d'abel 5
la dame qui attaque tout seul elle a un
déchet d'ici
dix à voir à noter d'ailleurs que
toujours dépassé le 40e donc qu'ils ont
eu leur âge ou de temps si tu étais au
final largement
le temps pour conclure ici donc il
souffre aux trois très bien joué le
jeu
quand je regarde aussi pour le battre
bien par l échec pardon regarder se fait
pas aussi des idées bat
pour qu'arrive à s'interposer
et saïbi bridge j'espère qu'il va me
prouver par contre j'y reste quelques
pièces à l'intérieur
on retire la machine
et voilà ça y est
désolé d'encore joie de mon truc je
pense à se fâcher n'accepte plus
que plume
[Musique]
est plus que tu paye le plus de tour
d'argent
noir morse touchés et bbb
on verra pour la suite
du combat est hélas tout et comme je
disais on a dépassé les quarantièmes
prégnant qu'il a tout son temps pour
elle si c'est par la loi devrait pas
tarder a abandonné 1 ici il ya plus
d'échecs
et le pion c'est là bientôt partie à des
réseaux de maths sais
c'est complètement finie et baby doc qui
devrait le plus court attrapé en tête
visite avec cette victoire avec les
noirs et tu vois 45 qui ajoute qu'ils
retournent finalement dans la partie que
la bd on disait tout à l'heure
ça coûte cher je paye à peu près de zéro
chaque heure
quand même
et 5,6 euros par jour en faveur
ça va du coup donc c'est pas toi trois
prises
torje a été jouée par parra grands
débuts ce
qu'on avait envisagé donc le fougueux 2
qui est parti
wei selon l'image de total
300 avait dit on dans la note c'est la
case achat 4
les deux joueurs qui jouent qui sont
sous les 5000 m'étonne donc
c'est quand même très compliqué de la
position mb c'est tt joué
vraiment je garde de mon bébé 2e tour
dames b4 être obligatoire je pense
madame beckham seul coup
je vois que fatou modo maîtrise bien la
last of money le kebab
n'apparaître
servait tellement longtemps que j'ai pas
mangé de kebab quoi
il a pas en argentine oui mais voilà la
lazio non mais même en france je mange
pas des gamers
donc des cats la seule solution pour
bloquer cette colonne on voit qu'il ya
pas de points qu'à rester
voilà devant la tour
la carte ça ne pense pas qu'ils
échangent à voir si je l'aï récupéré son
pion
il pourrait pour le plus amer d'un
pardon il faut d'abord bouger une fois
excusez moi
je sais pas vous d'ailleurs
foot pas le temps ça peut être dangereux
vraiment
habitué à jouer dans les deux sens le 20
juin je sais pas admettons fou je sais
pas ou peu importe
il va récupérer être champion parce
qu'il ya parfois trois contrôles
mais ce qu'il a envie de jouer cette
finale où certes peut-être pour après
c'est un petit peu parce qu'il est le
meilleur structure
à mon avis va essayer de garder les
dames sur l'échiquier des revoilà 6
passes d'armes ces 7 6 il a échangé
parce que le roi est faible le sien vous
il est pas
là déjà il a déjà connu des jours plus
paisibles à leroy de carson mais ça va
il va se cacher
ok la position est très chaude il a
même l'impression est grande et lucile
va essayer de tenir et le reste à
6 ou à jouer si cette fois joué jusqu
aux orages ou quoi peut-être rester je
propose ou sur cette partie ouais je
vais en attendant le 40e au juste ont
permis gros taureau vinci park andriat
il va finir aussi jouer encore une fois
bien pour moi ok bon bien on y reviendra
du coup que ça dure elle
peut-être pas si mal en vraie revue ce
qu'ils avaient avant
il a peut-être obtenu ce qu'ils
pouvaient avoir de moins qu'hier
c'est pas ce que tu dis pas tout mais tu
sais pas comment je les commande le
canada abbas et je pense que
avec du
genre cela compte de mal à trouver son
sens
aux journaux frites fromage cependant
comme
fromage
s km du fromage dans la position à
quinssaines
c'est
à dire non
mais c'est pas la même position que
l'acta dans ses bras il tricote
arrive au 40e coup
bonjour un pack de là dedans s'il vous
plaît
ça à peu près à ce que l'on
pense qu'il va revenir
aux passagers une suggestion
l'ordinateur stouff
g2c réglos est d'ailleurs ses vues par
grand des lieux bien joué
si tu manges je tends fils la dame avec
un pion au passage
ça c'est ce que quinssaines aurait
publié ce court j'ai l'impression qu'il
fait là vous
pas que du ski fait l'amour
c'est chiant secours
way to rage c'est un coup bas
d'une tour achète c'est pas bon signe
c'était actifs devient passif
ouais il faut que le fonds soit way we
were je sais pas je pense que magnus
îlots il a raté un
il a dû rater ce coup ici
c'est qu'ils attaquent la dame burundi
va bouger l'aide et bombay ses joueurs
tout s'est joué par magnus
magnus tout le sel qui est dans la place
sitôt achète
et si tu veux si moureu montrera à
partie une fois qu'on aura terminé les
anecdotes au 40e pourra pour à la
rejouer rapidement on va laisser finir
la crise de temps puisqu'il est
moins de trois minutes aux deux joueurs
pour atteindre le 40e course devrait
aller très vite
alors juste pour info duda et karine ça
a bien répété au quai vauban aussi
redouté sur doutez-vous pareil partie
spectaculaire mais qui s'est terminée
par la paix
et le reste le jour encore donc
grandi luce je pensais l'arc un petit
peu de poil de la bête à mon avis la
toussaint cette tour d'un petit peux tu
dire excellent jeu reprend un peu
d'initiative
vient peut-être pour gagner un temps
avec sa dame c'est aussi la bonne
nouvelle donc la tour de contrôle puis
la case
et le roi ya pas trop de bonnes cases
mais déplore ici huit mois
mais là j'ai fait écouter car abattement
c4 du coup la date je sais pas si tu
enlèves 3 pour gagner moi je lui tu
sais que tu as toujours fait ce thème
question maintenant est ce un tour
c'est vrai
et est ce que
oui là je souhaite revenir du g7 où tu
vas falloir j'imite
à je n'ai pas vu qu'on
a peut-être des idées de vous éclater à
temps les gens roulent jouer on va mars
qui seront joués pour un chef d'un des
trois échecs c'est la partie faussée car
oui mais s'adapte nice je pense qu'il va
la plonger 3
juste pour
angers
137 parce que derrière on enfile la dame
du coup comme g3 ce qu'on peut jouer à 8
est-ce qu'on peut jouer dernier 6 en
fait là ça marche pas
peut pas faire ses échecs pour aller
gagner ensuite
j'habite ici
ouais ça marche pas
être plus malin que mon courage émission
pour un futur plus besoin de points que
c'est un combat mais y aller chanter
terme ici
et là les velours ils craignent
pas grand chose en lien avec benfica
mardi plus
s est jouée par exemple des vieux ouais
je
pense vraiment qu'il a raté un magnus
ce qui n'était pas du tout obligé de
rentrer l'adoré c'est d'un parti comme
je croiserai d'alger 3 mt 6
du coup il devrait peut-être s'en sortir
le joueur suédois
septèmes g6 pour le coup je vois pas un
mot ou la verve là je vois pas ce qu'est
ce qui pourrait faire d'autant parce que
bon ben là il a composé ya les cours
bien sûr mais elles sont focale très
beau verbe et ouais mais donc de la
perle mais n'ont logiquement ça devrait
ici parce que même la tour à tour à la
défense qu'une page de
ses dreadlocks à un petit peu en fait il
a pensé répéter gagner du temps et les
oublier ce temps les deux ont très bien
joué de la part de grandes loges
et du coup c'est ce qu'il a perdu deux
bâches pose de cloche là nul ici
alors on revient la partie est ce que
madame je suis bien sûr été joué l
échange des dames qui part
pour prendre ne reste plus que
deux quoi jouer
ouais ouais c'est le sens qu'il est déçu
mais il fait sa tête de 18,2 j'ai raté
un truc assez sûr c'est sûr qu'ils aient
oublié ton je veux
pas pressée car savait capable
même avec un tournoi je pense qu'elle
est capable de presser une façon d'une
autre ici mais
je n'ai pas comment être tour g8 très
intéressant pour s'éviter a été jouée
dans un tour j'ai vite pour menaces
tourcoing h2 et sûr comme pour g2 d'un
bon là c'est peut-être courage de
commandes
courage
400 style gauche de catch qui commence
et s'arrête mais bon ça peut plonger
vous être maman dans l'idée parcours h4
la sq est pas si quand c'est que tu peux
laisser g7 et manger la peine peut être
des fois en dix ans en contrôle chez
vite après
basta du fou des trois-quarts y ait
encore des petits des petites idées coib
mais bon là on est au 39e courrier je
veux dire que dans un coup
les gens en cinq minutes de plus pour et
pétrir la position non mais sinon
je pense pas rendu avec une heure à la
pendule en tout cas sur une carotte
c'est beaucoup c'est le tour g25 tient
une faute apparemment tu vois la barre
qui se fâche
donc attention bafodé 3 à l'idée que je
mentionnais
est un peu négligents peut-être watch
ces dialectes couleurs posées on a parlé
de l'usprt avec ce fond pedn l'avion de
ligne à bord alors là il fallait faire
un coup précède plus
là tu peux avoir des problèmes encore je
pense
voir si 47 trophée des trois voies
mais je serais surpris que nous allons
peut-être que dans des lycées dit qu'ils
avaient non il peut pas assez sûr que ça
perd tout de suite répond ces bleus là
c'est complètement fini puisque moi je
dis est ce qu'il a fait sur fond d 3
elle a dû prévoir un truc quoi
par ailleurs ramené une pièce ici il va
perdre ce qui
advient tout ça
il veut céder de
hockey
objectivement il devrait réussir à
retomber sur ses pattes mais ouais mais
là il a eu à peine la chance d'arriver
au 40e way est normalement départ d'une
course qui a vu beaucoup croient trouver
la quarantaine c'est passionnant qui
peut la gagner c'est bien lui ici on
devrait avoir une partie dure en tout
cas des mouchards stouff
ça reste intéressant
remonter la partie ben oui mais vraiment
pas ses envies de l'écho
a bien sûr quelques pourra créer donc on
a vu que c'était une sicilienne avec g4
comme grands débuts j'avais déjà joué
contre rapport
il ya deux jours
c'est bien choisi une autre approche
et on a lu ensuite donc enfin 3,3 ici
et on récupère la pièce c'est que le
cavalier pu protéger
on ne veut pas de vous l'a rendu la
pièce comme s'agrandit bus
et cars scène quatre des cinq hommes 16
oz sacrifiera culturel avec
un si gros délits c'est peut-être pas
été dit pas précis
comme l'impression que c'est qu'un
celles qui prenaient
l'avantagé à refuser la répétition de
couleurs
et enfin
de nouveau refusé la répétition et la
boutique il a raté ce fameux gros
intermédiaires
qui a permis à agrandi juste de soulager
sa position
est quelque chose d'énorme
et donc on bat dans cette finale la cage
de football et d'ajouter quelques en
tout sur mon
attention et quand tu dans la dent à la
place de condé lui ce jour en jour qui
est bien meilleur que toi la position
comme des changes deux nuls mais il faut
encore un thé montrer que c'est nul
c'est difficile il ya la place de la
perle
donc intéressant de voir un peu comment
ça va se passer c'est que gaza ne va pas
raide au délà du phare il a sécurisé
corps
donc ça me fait dire qu'on reparte en
recul
terminée et on revient ensuite voir un
peu ce qui se passe dans l'un des
moments de partie savard stumpf a tout
de suite accepté
[Musique]
il
où
[Musique]
là
bonsoir à tout le monde de tous on
revient avec un geste évident puisque
pendant la pause aurait fait part à la
petite caméra qu un vent de forest avait
abandonné ouais
alors comment se terminer à noyarey
complètement ont été blessés lors vous
avez dit que c'était complètement fou du
diable on a juste eu un coût était là il
a le droit je crois
d'âme des uns et c'était l'abandon c'est
pas beaucoup trompé bonne forez du goût
qui règne sa quatrième partie des vieux
tournoi
le petit pouvoir de thé fait pas aussi
régulier que l'an dernier où il avait
créé la surprise en nombre assez
imposante et la dure défaite avec les
blancs oui là il a pris des risques mais
ça s'est retourné contre lui david orr
été très précis aujourd'hui
stouff qui est parti d'un repaire du
tout donc utiliser le jaurès derrick est
donc très précis le début du tournoi il
s'est départi de plus tôt
oui pour trancher ce qui au final tout
rouge
philippe meric félicite aujourd'hui il
ya pas mal de nuages et soleil qui
squattent tous partis allumer la lumière
va adapter peut-être fibreuse
oui ça aussi
baby tv média qui a fait de partir de
cheveux à l'arrêt depuis que là mais
aujourd'hui il a profité
parfaitement avis que pris par votre
correspondant au contraire je pense
qu'il a été il était très beau tout
simplement je rase eric donc rejoint
visite en tête
une bonne opération de la vidéo qui a
fait une partie à ses propres risques
agressé concret possible elle a réussi à
bien bien de bien défendre denis rey a
contre attaqué
donc du coup la panique en scène je
crois qu'elle n'a pas avancé encore non
mais puis on a
on irait voir peut-être d'autres
français comment il en est arrivé là
ouais si tu veux il ce qui va réussir à
sauver la nul donc
marc andriat et vu qu'ils étaient en
souffrance
voilà il est exact pour la dame venait
d'arriver en belgique pour attaquer le
pion
il a rapatrié donc ça tout en dépensant
en espérant tenir un verre beaucoup de
faiblesses chez les noix et aucune chez
les blancs avec un four j'ai très bien
placés très solide
alors commencé à voler une tour m3 la
joueuse russe qui veut certainement
rajouter de la pression on conquiert
très logique hkd pour empêcher sa
h40 pêche pour g3 mais le pion le plo à
ce qui peut être faible à patrick karam
karam
d'ailleurs comme bourg il ne déçoit pas
avec damas si c'est la partie moi j'ai
le sentiment que c'est un miracle qu'il
soit en train de louer deux finales avec
un trou mois de la position actuelle
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle qui
espérait véhicule
caceres à 5 ici rien d'un coup un petit
air
des plus grands peintres n'ont en rien
mêlé à ce qu'on peut pas manger le pion
mais
ça a l'air vraiment c'est chez jcb 3
était joué depuis six
mois est très faible ici ou là je te
hura 7
pas bon c'est son idée le concept
peut pas bouger ça d'arbres parce que là
ce pion il peut pas bouger ce bon cheval
sur sa rampe de partout ça tours doit
rester la défense
sa part à croire que je vous ai pas
trouvé un gars ici
dam des quatre tours décèle
avec eux
jusque là on revient à tête une erreur
ici de revenir
du coup bas contre il a saisi sa chance
l'appui enfin 5-1 peut envoyer le pion
quoi
certainement les cirques tour segal
direct et r c'est plus malins du pouvoir
par laurent gbagbo pour ses prix de 5 e
et 6
et on récupère le pion c'est donc les la
can trouver des jolies ressources
tactile s'est accroché ou
bien cette finale va encore falloir
dépendants mais c'est assez miraculeux
même la fraude et villareal est un pion
de noël à un fou
de tours
[Musique]
est dure mais aux caisses et c'est quand
même pour lui je pense peut-être la
seule chance qu'il pouvait avoir un à
partie des procès de la tenir vu d'où
viendrait peut-être
mais normalement je pense qu'on la gagne
1,4 et blanc vont se créer un peu passé
aldama clavier puis ont arraché et après
on est cerné le roi sur le premier de
six mois dans cette atmosphère
mais bon
on stade et chance quand même de nul
surtout d'où il vient encore une fois ok
bah ça risque de durer pour le co
ça risque de durer du coup droit
principale
3 nuls pour l'instant
dubaï jean claude
thiry visiter tout dakar jaeckin et donc
babillard comme bien de loire qui s'est
imposé que les pièces devant il nous
reste trois parties le propos est
retourné chez caruana bon combat prat
qui va perdre 1 quasiment trois retours
en vallée bras
rapport et on a et c'est un co qui je
pense ne pas tenir sa
méga simplification est
staff et les joueurs vient d'appeler les
voir donc le renard il est louable on
est parti
alors on pas câble ouais on va revenir
quand on sera la position actuelle ouais
c'est de voir comment ils en sont
arrivés là
on en était là en plus en pleine
réflexion
honda avait vu que le coup beaucoup pour
les noirs il n'est pas le moins efficace
des ponceaux pions et d'abats 5 avec une
belle idée ça a été trouvé un parent par
famille
et malgré tout il n'a pas réussi à
derrière peut-être pas concrétisées donc
damas deux super coq à échanger les
dames et ses cadres la zone est donc ces
quatre pour rester avec le pion put
sévère bien pour cadres a quand même ça
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais
j'ai qu'un pion
wade à quelques deux pions passé lié par
un cavalier
établi
sais pas c'est quoi la caravane à sa
grande époque ça il a gagné tous les
lorrains avec les noirs
surtout contre un joueur il exerce et la
jambe et armés
et c6 logique
ces 3 ou 7 3
qu'elle accélère très logique el mundo
minogue est six fois je crois
moi je suis pour cette raison qu'elle le
connaît beaucoup carnacki fait une très
bonne partie
alors à quel moment il a il a laissé
échapper ses rois au retour à tous à la
barre que ça a pas l'air d'être le
meilleur coup pourtant cette nature et
l'origine
mais peut-être le problème ici c'est con
tre jeu assure se plonger
c'est peut-être ça qui a sauvé et si
penco
pour preuve de war bouge
au point un plan qui aurait chaque camp
moment puis ont pu sauver koi vélos
récupérés d'ailleurs c'est la partie
qui est celui-ci bâtisse salut à toi kvh
un kiwi sagan staff habite chaque paquet
apparemment pourtant honnêtement quand
on fait défiler les cours dans
l'impression qu'il a bien joué
il a fait de belles séquences de cours
il est resté naturel
est pas si facile en pratique
certainement
et la paire de fout des blancs
il a pu échanger par le temps et se
retrouver au québec l'adoption de moi
virtuellement parce que lui va tomber
ça va pas s'y fier
il suffit